you
you
welcome to the final day of the
we're going to go ahead and get started
so I'd ask everyone to take their seats
and I don't have any announcements today
because we're in the final stretch but I
just wanted to tell you that we are
starting with our first panel today
which will be followed by a short coffee
break around 11:00 and then after the
break at starting at 11:15 we'll invite
all of our panelists back up to the
stage for a final discussion and then
we'll conclude the conference so I'd
like to introduce our moderator for the
day been cut short and he'll be
introducing the first panel thank you
good morning good morning good morning
can you hear me okay okay first of all
let me say my name is Ben cash or and
I'm very sorry I couldn't make the
conference yesterday I had classes and a
faculty meeting but I saw the list of
speakers and I imagine it was a very
important productive day before I'd
reduce the speakers I want to give you a
little bit of my background so you know
where I'm coming from and these
questions so I am a political scientist
and I worked mostly on questions of
forest policy and governance and I began
my career looking at Canadian and US
forest policies and then realized
whatever happens in Canada in the u.s.
actually impacts other regions of the
world so I switched to Europe and then I
switched to private mechanisms like
forest certification and realize that
actually markets impact global dynamics
and now we're working on Southeast Asia
and the impact of certification and
things like legality verification on
really intractable problems like
deforestation and forest degradation so
out of all this research has come the
concern that if you look back in the
last 20 years of efforts to improve
forest policy and governance across the
world the challenge we find to
challenges that need to be overcome and
that I think this panel begins to
overcome and the first challenge is a
Kumal challenge now wacom moses game
that kids play in north america anyway
where you whack-a-mole with a hammer in
one circle and but in another circle the
mole comes back up over here and so you
have to hit the mole over here but then
in a third circle the mole comes up over
here okay the problem is that you saw
one problem somewhere and you caused
another problem somewhere else so often
people say that when we say the northern
spotted owl in the US Pacific Northwest
by reducing logging there you ended up
increasing logging in Indonesia in
Southeast Asia and so solving the
whack-a-mole problem becomes really
important for all of us collectively at
the global level but also at local
scales the other problem that's related
to the lacrimal problem is that because
that we by not addressing the
whack-a-mole problem we have very short
term attention spans regarding the
latest policy initiative or metaphor to
address these problems so if you go back
20 years what do we see we see five year
attention spans on policy instruments
and policy metaphors from tropical
boycott campaigns to global forest
convention efforts to forest
certification efforts to criteria and
indicators efforts and now we have red
plus and legality verification and now
we also have different framing so now we
we used to have forests by themselves as
be important and now it's forests if
climate is important with forests though
the problem definition is better that
way but the problem and their panels
we'll talk about is what happens when
you frame for us in a climate framework
and that we have the latest big forests
and food security and I hadn't me
thought it was before but now this is
the thing we all care about is forests
in food security because norms shape
when we think about these things and of
course now it's no longer ecosystem
management that ecosystem services and
so they matter if we have a service they
provide like when you go to a restaurant
and you order food if they provide a
service to you they've actually matter
ok so all these things
actually affect us because we really
want to create durable approaches to
addressing these problems that don't let
us in five years from now having a new
metaphor will be enough food security
but now something else we haven't
thought about right because we keep
getting frustrated by the pace and scale
of change and so I think these this
panels allows us to think about these
questions in this kind of context do
they actually make a difference and how
might they actually be important so I
think this is gonna be a really
productive panel that regard one thing
we are going to be draconian on the time
limits that each panelist has because
the Q&A is always the best okay so I'm
announcing that I will not let the
panels go over there a lot of time I'll
actually stand up and stop them okay
that's the ground rule so we can have
our Q&A which means I also must stop
myself as well which I will now oh and I
do so our first presenter is Jacques
Pelini who was initially trained in
biology and agronomy and completed a PhD
Natural Resources studying the causes of
deforestation in Madagascar from a
social science perspective so nicely
brings in these complementary views and
knowledge bases he worked in
international rural development and
conservation programs and currently
combines consulting work for us AI D
funded project F CMC which will learn
from Jacques that acronym is with
research activities at the University of
Illinois urbana-champaign both
addressing forest governance and read
policies in Africa and his titles
wonderfully provocative for thinking
about these questions that I just raised
red plus and the shifting cultivation in
DRC will adaptation and mitigation turn
maladaptive with that welcome Jacque
[Applause]
well thanks for the great opportunity to
be here ok I won't repeat the title the
title and they will go straight to the
subject
I guess you're familiar with the red
Prius already and with Cintiq activation
but in a few words red Prius is about
reducing emission from deforestation
through a mechanism which is based on
carbon trading so I will go straight to
the place where we did this field walk
what's the trick which button this one
ok so this presentation is by is based
on some field walk which was done by
three consultant including myself I was
with two national consultant recruiting
DRC Congo it's a walk then for the
project for West carbon market and
community which is a readiness project
financed by US ID so it's best not a
long time spending on the field
basically we went to two places which
you can see here and lingo MO and both
are in this ground forest of the Congo
Basin which is the second-biggest
rainforest in the world but this
presentation today is only based on
lingo mode the second site which you can
see on the top of the slide this is just
to show you an ID of the this grant
forest from the plane which walked us to
that place because that place is quite
remote there's no hard going there you
have to fly you have to even run to
plane to go there and this is a typical
settlement you find in this area so you
can see reward but it's very narrow it
can only be practiced only be used by
motorbikes and bags and you can see the
the people living around the house
smallholder farmers and I practice
shifting cultivation which you can see
on this slide and which consists in
clearing a piece of roast or secondary
vegetation and then OSU burned the the
vegetation you can directly plant in
this case corn and cassava which are the
two main crops cassava provides a stable
and calm is a is a cash crop because
they transform the corn into alcohol and
alcohol is easy to transport you can put
five 125 litres of alcohol on the bag
and it so it's easy to transport to
someplace where you can you can sell it
here you can see a material field of
cassava and you can see the vegetation
around so the landscape is actually a
mosaic of secondary vegetation and
fields until a distance of about five
kilometers from the world and beyond
that distance is too far away it will
result in too much transportation cost
for carrying the harvest and so people
stay close to the world and the rest of
the area is a grand forest that you saw
on the form a picture but close to their
house they also have other older systems
they have some sort of small forest
garden you can see here some coffee in
the middle and coffee actually used to
be a very important cash crop in the
past so currently people are living out
of the shifting cultivation system
oriented to corn and cassava but in the
past they were focusing on perennial
crops because until the 80s there were
actually some trucks some cows coming
into this area there was more
infrastructure in the country and buyers
came and the price of coffee and other
perennial crops was higher so people
were living actually much better than
they do now and now you only find a few
remaining coffee trees like here and
they also cultivate palm oil which also
used to provide some income but now it's
almost abandoned and you can see also
banana trees on this picture here you
can see the coffee harvest which is only
sold locally and here you can see a
rubber tree plantation there's also a
large plantation
plantation close to this area which used
to hire a much labor force but now it's
a not really close but it doesn't
produce a lot because the price of
rubber is too low
although that could be a comeback of
rubber tree cultivation because of the
price apparently coming up a little bit
but every family I have a small plot of
rubber trees but they don't have as then
because the price is too low and nobody
buys here you can see the tool that
people use it's mostly the machete
shifting cultivation you don't plow the
land when you do filthy cavity vision
you just sew directly
I've told you burn but the plow is used
for making small gardens and also
because NGOs did introduced some new
techniques and this is what we are going
to see on the next pictures well in
compliment to agriculture people also go
to the forest for hunting and fishing
and collecting various projects and
that's very important complement to the
economy also now there is no not many
animals to hunt the country was at war
during ten years and until four during
the 90s people were actually leaving
their settlement close to the Horde and
they hide in the forest to avoid the red
from you know the military groups and
during that time they really extensively
lived from the forest which was then
like a shelter but the consequence is
that there is no much game remaining and
so they have still does a small camp in
the forest like you see on this picture
but now they really have to rely on
agriculture because there's not much to
find no not so many things to find in
the forest here another picture of
forest camp well you can see also the
the corn going they establish some small
fields still shifting cultivation okay
now a few pictures from the walk of the
NGO and there's an intervention financed
by USAID cafe program and it involves
the NGO African Wildlife Foundation in
partnership with the Center for
international agriculture tropical
agriculture and here you can see a
family showing his field and so you can
know
this is actually a club that used to be
practiced but it's supported by the
project which introduce new techniques
which consist of making a computation
blowing the land sowing in line and and
cultivating two and a half years the
same plot instead of just creating coal
and cassava which lasts about 30 north
and then abandoning the land into fallow
so it's the idea of intensification and
[Music]
but you can see that this has some
consequence so the rotation involves
some cereals like the the rice but also
some legumes like peanuts here ground
nut but the system has some consequence
on the environment and not so on the on
the economy you can see here winds
because the same plot you have a wheat
equation and there were women you know I
mean this system was supported by the
NGOs who Association of farmers which
include both men and women but after one
year or a little bit more the women
massively deserted the Association and
they explained us that this is because
they just can't afford to do that very
heavy work of getting rid of those weeds
so apparently the new system creates a
new workload that people can't manage
because of this weed invasion but we
have also - I have to mention that in
the same time that this system is also
for producing seedlings because the
project has a strategy of multiplication
of seeds and so they explain us when we
discuss this issue that in the single
step the farmer will appropriate the
system by themselves and there were it
will be more flexible so the technique
eventually could be a little bit
different from what is shown here but
still you have those idea of crop
rotation which I expect to be at the
core of the new technology that is
proposed and here you can see the weed
invasion and the project also introduced
cover crop which also have this effect
of covering the land and you can order a
hawk and the vegetation also develop in
this environment so probably this is
going to have an impact
the fellow vegetation on the recovery of
the forest after the cultivation and so
this is also something that should be
looked at to really know the impact of
the technique on their environment okay
so you saw the big picture of those
farming systems so now let's synthesize
a little bit what was really striking
for us is that we felt like there are
really two ways to see intensification
one way is the intensification the
proposed being to reduce the land that
is intact cultivation so you can keep
more forests which will then you know be
compatible with a read policy so the
farmers they have the idea of
progressively intensifying that means
progressively reducing the fallow period
but still doing shifting cultivation
evenly they complement with a few other
things like maybe perennial crops but
for the for the the project that
intervenes and has read in in the in the
back mind the idea is that shifting
cultivation is bad shifting cultivation
destroys the forest who there has to be
something else so it's the idea of
alternative completely changing
radically the system by introducing
competition plowing the land etc and I
think this contrast needs to be paid
attention so what what are the causes of
this contrast well one of the course is
the criteria that people have in mind to
think about the new system from a farmer
what matters is how much they can
produce with the LeBeau you know but the
project has in mind yield any agronomist
any extension agenda speak with will be
concerned by yields but he doesn't tell
you how much you produce he doesn't does
tell you how much the land is producing
but if you have high yield but that it
requires so much work that you only can
cultivate a small piece of land you will
have higher lead and lower production so
that's one important aspect another one
is that project month will eradicate
fire and erosion and I am NOT saying
fire version I would and saying maybe we
have to a little bit neurons these ideas
another point is that they they look at
a very local scale whereas sometimes you
need to
look at the molar scale what things
happen so for example people are moving
all the time and people make decision
about which kind of land a coochie vet
they can move to the forest but they can
also move to other area which are going
to be attractive for the reasons like
infrastructure school for the kids and
you have people moving to Center urban
center even if there is no good land and
they can cultivate in Savannah if they
have the means to do that so that what
scale also has to be looked at and
fourth point is that farmers are not
first as rational economic agents so
every time the project has a failure it
always considers because the the the
farmers are not well educated enough
they need to be sensitised etc instead
of wondering that maybe it's the
technology proposed that support by the
project that's not good and should be
questioned and then it's summarized a
little bit all those things but politics
and reductionist science you know far
away if occasion and this garage
reflexivity well what does that mean
I think I keep that for the discussion
because I think I'm a little bit late
and so the last slide is about you know
is like a conclusion so so there's a
need to support a broader range of
options to live for us to choose among
these options to value the women's level
also and their participation and maybe
to create incentive of or instead of
always having just a plan stop the most
demonization and romanticization of late
you and sees beyond science and that has
said and also think about our common
sense our experience of the reality and
not just the data we can extract fall
from it Thank You Jacques and please say
you you being the first person to be
part of this draconian effort to stop
things right be and it's kind of the
Academy Awards you know when people come
up behind you and if I can have music
playing next time that'd be really
useful but thank you that was a really
great start and now I want to jump to
lie just claim her for legal reasons
people in TV land this is important okay
this is a disclaimer there we go okay
nice thank you thank you and of course
you can go back here likewise when we're
communicating
okay fantastic okay this is working out
really well yes okay so now I'm going to
introduce to you questions first pardon
me
questions first in between and then
questions after pardon me we're two
minutes for questions I have a quick
question could you address a little bit
why the multi-year use of the same plots
would suddenly introduce weeds as
opposed to the first year why weeds
aren't present in that if you go to a
voice you would see nothing especially
if it is a primary for as nothing is
going on the ground because another
share of the trees the weeds are not
growing so if you clear the forest you
don't have any seeds any weed seed
because there were no grass is going in
the forest so you plant your seeds and
no other city is going to germinate you
only your crop is going but now of
course the seeds you know that can be
bought by the wind or by the animals or
but by whatever people are working so
little by little they come and they can
multiply very fast so you stay longer
time you are more weeds coming
red actors who were coming in with this
with a set of assumptions that you
listed for us were they Congolese who
were the actual actors in this case so
at the moment there is no red project
but there's the idea of preparing the
ground to make red project being
implemented later on because there is a
large you know very important word
policing in Congo so there's a national
committee a red national committee which
is preparing the country for red which
is supporting a number of national
projects which are pilot project they
are actually six plus three private
projects but there is one of those I
mean the one private red project in the
other sides which I do not present but
in this place at the moment there is no
red projects but the report reflects a
little bit what other project or what
word project are doing for example I
didn't mention that here but they are
making the zoning of the area in order
to define an area dedicated to agree
with you and an area dedicated to
conservation so when there will be a red
project this conservation area will be
the area which will justify carbon
credits so it's more like a preparedness
and I have to say also that you know the
comment I made on those on those on the
system you know are absolutely not
comments about you know the work of an
organization because it's really it's
the world logic that determines the fact
that farmers are proposed those
technology that might be not not the
best adaptation it's because you know it
has to be no burning the vegetation
because there is red behind and I really
discussed with the the staff on the
project they are totally aware of those
of those issues but you know they are in
the system they have to play with that
system so just to say you know that I
don't want to blame any organization any
people are walking in those place we're
all doing a very difficult job but even
if there is no red
there is a red spirit a red logic and
that spirit means don't use fire don't
clear any forest and then that means you
know transform radically your system in
a way that's actually quite unrealistic
I think is the time up for Q&A okay so
we're gonna come back to Q&A a lot at
the end when all three panels are
finished speaking so we'll have time for
that
in a few minutes okay so thank you very
much this just nicely speaks to the
often perverse impacts we have when we
introduce broad scale instruments
without thinking about the very
important on the ground consequences and
I rate them to Jacques for this now I'm
going to introduce Kathleen who's that
okay okay
caffeine kachelle who is a biologist by
training has a master's degree in
environmental science from the
University of San Paolo and is currently
pursuing an MPA at the School of
International and public affairs at
Columbia University she has worked for
six years at a leading environmental NGO
in the Brazilian Amazon forests
agricultural frontier and as the deputy
executive coordinator at the Institute
instituto centro de vida her work
addressed a combination of environmental
issues management strategies initiatives
to influence public policy and corporate
social responsibility
so with that well join me in welcoming
caffeine who will speak on the topic
balancing large-scale soyabean expansion
with smallholders agriculture lessons
from the brazilian forest agricultural
frontier thank you
up I got it's better good morning
everyone my name is Karen I'm really
happy to be here so I'm gonna talk a
little bit about some lessons learn from
the Brazilian forest agricultural
frontier so the agenda of the
presentation I'm going to talk about the
Amazon some storico drivers of
deforestation some initiatives from the
soy supply chain and some part public
policies to small holders in the Amazon
and future challenges so first of all
when we think about the Amazon we have
to think about three different concepts
first is the Amazon biome that's the
Green Line then we have the Amazon
watershed that's the blue line and there
is a legal concept that's called with
the legal Amazon that's a political
boundary that's the shaded area on that
on that myth so when we think about the
brazilian amazon we have a population of
21 million inhabitants it represents 6%
of the Brazilian GDP total area is 5
million square kilometers this is half
of the size of the United States we have
24% of protected areas 21% of indigenous
land and 12% of small land owners so in
the map the green areas are the
protected areas in the orange yellowish
areas are the indigenous land so when we
think about the Amazon we have to think
about the first station as well nowadays
almost 20% of the forest is already
cleared this area is more it's bigger
than the state of Texas so it's a pretty
huge area and but at the same time we
know that the first station rates has
been reducing over the time and this is
due to a lot of effects first we can
mention some public policies in Brazil
fiscalization has increased technology
is much better to control an inch
monitor the deforestation and we can
think about economic crisis of the
prices come off the commodities we
think also at some initiatives from the
private sector and this all do this all
combined lead to a decrease of
deforestation rates however degradation
has been increasing a lot recently this
is due to illegal timber extra
extraction so when we think about
historical drivers of deforestation in
Brazil in the Amazon we have to think
about cattle ranching 80% of the area
that is already cleared has pasture on
it and the average is one cow per
hectare so with a very low intensive
production but other stakeholders like
smallholders are important and timber
extraction as well and we think about
agricultural we have to think about soil
so I have played an important role it's
not very important right now but
historical it is important nowadays we
have around 9 millions of hectares of
soybean planted in Brazil in the Amazon
and this represent 8 percent of the sort
of the total soy that is produced in the
world so it's very significant most of
the soil goes through Europe but also
for Asia especially India and China and
this soy is used mostly for feed the
animals like cow and chicken and pigs
but it's also used for food and fuel all
of these agricultural expansion leads to
some social and environmental problems
we can mention some health effects due
to pesticides or deforestation carbon
emission loss of biodiversity but also
problems with
indigenous people traditional
communities to deal with all of these
problems the soil supply chain has
launched in 2004 an initiative and
international multi-stakeholder
initiative that's called around to even
responsible soil these at this
initiative we have NGOs we have traders
we have chemical industries and we have
at some point some governments and the
producers there are all sit together and
since 2007 they have
développé I standard tort certification
that address all of these challenges so
legal responsible labor conditions
community relations environmental
responsibility and good agricultural
practice and nowadays we have already 1
million tons of soil that is already
certified and the Dutch government made
a commitment that after 2006 they're
gonna buy only our TRS are only
responsible so I or more restricting
this so it's already one step it's not
the solution but it's a good solution so
regarding Brazil we have another
initiative that's called the soya
moratorium that's was launched in 2006
and all the traders made a commitment
not to buy soy that was planted in in
the Amazon or in recent deforestation
area after 2006 so last year less than
1% of the Amazon was planted with soy so
we can see that this is a very
successful initiative as well so and
when what about the small holders when
we think about small holders in the
Amazon we have rural settlements more
than 2,000 and this is 77 million
hectares we have seven more than 700
thousand families living there but at
the same time they are responsible for
one third of deforestation in Brazil and
but at the same time they are very
important for food production in Brazil
so why are they important because if we
do not have some policies or some ways
to keep those small holders on their
land they're gonna lease those lands to
big land owners for soy producers or
cattle rangers these will lead to a
situation of food insecurity for them
but also for the population who lives in
the area and this can cause some social
problems in the city and so that's a
very crucial stakeholder that we need to
address and to address all these
challenges the Brazil government has
launched a program that's called the
zero hunger program and for instance
school lunch at least 30%
of the school lunch must come from small
holders in the region or in the
surrounding this is a so we are bringing
access to market for them there is
another program that's called food
acquisition program so the Brazilian
government by the production so we are
providing access to markets for those
small holders and we have a credit
that's promising national program for
strengthening family agriculture that's
a credit line that allows small holders
to get its credit and to invest in their
land but most of these investments are
done in cattle ranching in northern
agriculture so we need to provide them
some technical assistance to technical
assistance to be able to convince them
to produce some food so future challenge
so we know that there is an increasing
demand of Asian markets especially for
soy and the soy it's going to expand in
some place it can happen in the Amazon
or it can happen in in Savannah what is
going on right now in Brazil all the
expansion has been in other biomes so
how we do how do we deal with this
conversion of native vegetation we have
an issue like all of this region of the
Amazon is considered like the
breadbasket of the world but at the same
point we import food there are usually
in the state of mato grosso and all of
the food that was eaten there was
brought from other state of Brazil so
what is the point of producing food for
the role and not being able to produce
our own food and regarding smallholders
as I told we have to keep or we have to
maintain those pop those stakeholders
and Airlines so they can be able to
produce food for them and for for
Brazilian population in general but for
this they need technical assistant and
we need access to market and we can
think about public-private partnerships
to access them to market as well and
another big issue that is coming in the
Amazon right now is oil dams mining and
reduction of protected areas these will
impact not only small holders but these
you can reach more deforestation and at
some point can affect the production of
commodities as well so in conclusion I
would say that there is no silver bullet
to address the issue of reducing
deforestation and to provide food
security but it's crucial that we have
to think that this area is not an empty
space is not only a forest we have a lot
of people there we have to to make to
bring some solutions for especially for
the small holders regarding food
security issues we have some public
policy should to address these
challenges but at the same time we have
I think the private sector can play a
very important role on addressing those
issues and as civil society we can ask
those companies to be more responsible
in their production and yeah on the
commercialization so thank you for your
time on time and I'm happy to take any
questions
[Applause]
thank you very much mere time for a
couple of questions reading two minutes
now and then we'll have a lot more after
I'm you may have said this but I'm
interested in what stimulated the
formation of the roundtable and
responsible soy production was that from
the private sector and if so what was
the stimulus for actually getting
organized and doing something different
actually that was a NGO led initiative
so that was a period that was a lot of
roundtable starting but the private
sector reacted pretty well and they
really engage themselves on this and we
have all the traders there and we have
all the industries there and because
they really needed to address the issue
of deforestation of environmental bad
practice or labor conditions so they
needed to make their image better and I
would say that it took a while for us to
really get them engaged so they were
just dialogue in dialogue in dialogue in
and just postponing the commitment but
since I don't know almost eight years we
have some pretty good commitments and
right now we need to to enhance those
those commitments from the private
sector but I think I believe in in this
platform so I think we can increase the
responsible soy production two quick
questions
first is talk about the roundtable again
if you think that somebody should be
there and it's not currently
participation participating the wrong
table and I don't know if it's a
question for an hour later but you touch
a lot of issues that we're talked about
before
one of the main shows when we talk about
any kind of production in the Amazon its
land tenure so if you could touch this
in some point an hour later okay Lentini
one is a tricky one
so Brazil has a very in stable or
doesn't have very clear roles rules on
land tenure but there are some for
instance nowadays to monitor
deforestation
right now or to register the property
they are not asking for land tenure
titles only if you as long as you are
there and you are producing you can
register your property so this can be
monitored this is very good progressive
public policies that some governments
has has a has taken
I think Jeff mentioned this yesterday
when we told when we talked to us about
the forest code and regarding small
holders they doesn't have the land
property on they they receive the land
and only after ten years if they are in
this land they receive the land title I
believe that they should receive the
land title right now because they are
responsible for what they are doing on
the land but this is a huge and very
complicated issue in Brazil and when we
think about the round table I think that
was a multi-stakeholder International
House a round table but now we have to
bring to the table the governance I
think if the Brazilian government could
be involved in the round table maybe
this could be a little bit more
strengthened okay thank you very much
and we'll come back to these questions
in detail at the break but we've got a
very good idea about how in this
presentation a number of different
problems and initiatives are interacting
to potentially produce some important
results so thank you very much caffeine
and now I want to turn to Nepal and dr.
Jaganath at Akari
who has carried out a great deal
research on natural resources management
encompassing themes like agricultural
development land reform and management
participatory forest management
biodiversity urban environment and
climate change and food security I his
focus is on South Asia especially Nepal
and has written and edited a number of
books and articles on these these topics
I think his talk promises to be very um
fascinating because of the potential
he's going to look at at the ability of
thinking of forests as edible for us in
resting some of the problems in this
title is edible forest rethinking the
pawls forest governance in the era of
food insecurity so join me in welcoming
Jaganath thank you well thank you so
much for your kind introduction I'm very
honored to be here to present my
presentation as well as to interact with
the students and faculty members I
learned a lot in this process we all
know that Nepal's forest policies have
changed a lot in the last say 50 years
so originally it's a kind of people
managed for history before the
modernization of the state and then as
the state was modernized it was a kind
of a very centralized forest management
which didn't work in most of the cases
and then the policymaker again realized
that we need to have people's
participation in forest management
especially in the context of Nepal
because of the biophysical condition as
realized the nature of the economy that
call for the participatory forestry
which we know by the name of community
forestry which is quite extensive and
which is relatively successful in a
sense but we have new challenges also at
the same time these challenges are like
food insecurity is growing I know also
challenges come from the growing
landlessness there's a kind of conflict
between I mean conflict between
landlessness landless people versus
forestry and if we if you look into the
newspapers newspaper certain pal you'll
see almost every day that there has been
conflicts somewhere in the forest
peoples wanting to occupy land for
settlement or further
Avik insulting so this is the context in
which I say
that we have to convert at least the
community forestry into it evil forest
so time we need a new style of
governance for that that is the main
point I mean it's not a single resource
I'm going to tell about it's my own
personal experience Italy I draw various
points for my biggest wishes so it's
kind of pulling together just to give
you a context just to give you a context
this is the region where I I was burned
we studied and nowadays I do research so
this is my kind of area why and I focus
here so looking back I know that these
are the these are the forest product we
used to derive when we're kids from the
forest
so from the high mountain we used to
have all these vegetables two slides and
they have now sold in the market so it's
a kind of a link so people are selling
in the market and then there is in the
third one it's wild honey it's very
popular there there is a flame
honey hunting in Nepal if you go to
youtube you can get the information
about it so I know I used to bring such
honey when I used to go to that place
and there are so many types of
vegetables fruits some are consumed
within the village and some are sold in
the market so it's a kind of a forest to
used not only for timber fuel would
unfold but also for the food so this is
the context
so I mean based on that we can develop a
kind of a framework which links forestry
and food security so there are different
companies I think it was discussed in
the in the first session in the keynote
address and also yesterday there are so
many components of force activity and
the forest is directly as well as
indirectly linked to different
components of the force activity and if
we have good institutions then it can
lead to better food security so this is
nothing so the recent concern is like
there is a growing food crisis there's
quite it's very evident and there are
many wishes showing this and there is
growing line lessness and there is
conflict in resource use and there is
still deforestation and there's I mean
policy circle there debate about whether
it is forest or farm or whether we
should go for forest as well as farm
together and I think there is declining
biodiversity and Nepal is one of the
hottest spots is affected by climate
change and Himalayas are facing the
highest rise in temperature as compared
to other regions but despite that
despite the the linkage between forestry
and food security that have Sun so there
were still institutional barriers to
link forests and food security so I'm
more concerned with these various now so
landlessness situation I mean it's a
country of small landholders the Everest
line holding is 0.7 hectare of a family
it's not for an individual family 0.7
and then hectare and then there were
about 25 percent households living in
rural areas which are more or less
functionally landless so so so they need
some kind of access to food I mean food
can be obtained through
different ways but forests can be a
source for food so it's a small holder
farming in the PAL and there's not much
Isco for expanding agriculture land
together of the geo for geological
condition and deforestation is still
growing
and forest increment is still one of the
consequences of a landlessness medieval
forest which I mean giving food products
and emphasis in community waste forest
management that's what I mean by
medieval forests can help to supplement
I don't mean it will completely fulfill
the four security requirement we need
food production in there giggles or lane
but it can supplement in the info so so
it's not a kind of we can there are
still scope for increasing intensity of
cropping in the agricultural land that
is there that's one opportunity but at
the same time we can also increase food
security through edible forest I'm but
there as I said before there were
institutional barriers for this so this
I mean there was so many there is some
historical roots how the forest
bureaucracy is established and why it
doesn't give much impetus on food
because forest bureaucracies was more
concerned only with timber it was a
timber focused forest management and and
there's institutional barriers just to
link I think we discussed yesterday also
agriculture is one vertical organization
for history is another there's no
communication between them that's
another problem and forest organization
they do not look into forests they say
it's not a chapter it belongs to another
one looking into various policies and
forestry acts they also constrain were
growing food in photographs in community
- forests so there are problems in
in terms of raising livestock as well as
getting food and community forests still
have timber and biodiversity as their
main goal so these are some of the
barriers so how to how to address some
of the barriers I'll just focus on the
governance issue I mean making a
community forces edible forest also mean
is a new land use policy and in many
cases such type of language policy have
what we didn't about because I have got
some experiences and then and then
various policies are needed that helps
people to produce food and we also have
to think about REDD+ if we restrict
forest use then I think there are
questions about weight loss and then
there were few experiment with
certification especially in the use of
an TF is like medicinal hops that comes
from forest and the experience shows
that there are some positive things it
can help and I neither the most
important in this would be like equity
participation sharing of the benefits
and development of the user committees
we select into these aspects if this
happens there is a kind of a cooperation
from all the people and then it can be -
oil so these are the new governance
ideas but we need to we are thinking of
kind of experimenting some community for
estates edible forest and and in future
we'll see how it goes yeah we decided
thank you
again two minutes for questions right
now and then we'll open it up
I think thanks for talk I wouldn't -
because say a little bit more about the
sorts of policies that are either being
suggested or already implemented - to
link or to make voice more accessible to
people in a food security perspective I
know you had a little bit of text under
the under the second to last slide but
if you could say a little bit more about
what's happening or what's proposed in
that in that context you mean in terms
of securing more food so one of your
suggestions from Cleveland governance
was to to create policies that allow
people to use undeveloped forests more
in a different way for for food security
yeah I mean the thing is now the the de
Forest Act doesn't permit people to grow
food except for one or two crops and
then and that has some kind of adverse
impact on for security so if people are
allowed to cultivate crops without
destroying much of the canopy I mean
food production would increase and I'm
mustardy as you say in the picture there
are women who cultivated there are poor
people who who use it so in that sense
it could be helpful for food security so
some main thing is that
are you mentioned briefly something
about human rights issues related to
forests can you comment a little more on
that yeah I mean this landlessness has
become a very political thing and
because if a landless household has a
settlement in the forest
then they will have a right to settle
right to a shelter and then and that
will lead to in my opinion a very
haphazard forest encroachment and then
there are indigenous people who have
been managing forests in many places
there we didn't about there are many
indigenous people having and they need I
mean we also signed this one six nine
ILO and six nine that means we have to
respect their rights and many of the
foods have culturally sensitive they are
required during festival in various
things and so if we give total rights
for them to manage community forestry
and produce food that is required for
security and food security also in
Colusa furnishing food required for the
cultural purpose so that would help
thank you for your talk enough do you
know of a region or do you see regional
variations in community forestry user
groups and their methods of maybe
getting around or improvising strategies
that that bypass the forest act yeah I
mean that's quite interesting you see
the indigenous management prior to like
Forest Act private ago government
bureaucracy controlling all the forests
there was a variety of management style
local people had the one management
style and the way they used to pay the
forest guard or rotate themselves to
look after the forest so there was
various nums even now after the Forest
Act 1993 who is led to community
forestry spirit there are some variation
but it's not as diverse as it was
because of the regulation that is in the
act it has tried to kind of homogenize
the style of management but it still
there are very smallest scope to go
around the law and in some cases yes
people have done it I'm the Forester
government forester have done the blind
eye to how people manage it table now so
we'll begin to have a round table
response to your questions and I want to
say a couple of things which is first
that and all of these speakers and their
presentations really illustrate the
point that would ever be trying to do at
the global level with policy
interventions to address these
on-the-ground challenges we better think
very carefully about the local context
and understand it very well or you might
design policies that have very perverse
impacts and the problems we care about
now we all know that but in reality
rarely do we actually read
design our international efforts to
address these problems and it's that
link that is so important and that these
papers and presentations is nicely
illustrate
okay I'm gonna ask the first question to
get us going now the theme is we get to
be provocative we're in a university so
this is a chance to actually raise ideas
not just be conservative and and you
know not really changing things up okay
so I'm going to try and change things up
a little bit okay with the idea that
this is a big seminar okay it's not me
talking just an idea out there that I
have to be raising okay so with that in
mind this is a question I'm going to
pose and behind the question is a
concern again every is before that it
just seems that for the last 20 years we
have these great ideas great instruments
great metaphors and then they don't end
up doing what we want and so we redesign
new metaphors and new ideas and go study
them and find out that they're not quite
doing what we want and so we have new
metaphors and it's a vicious cycle
okay so that's behind my question so I
want to ask you all three view is to
reflect on for a second
forgetting about anything now that's
happening it turns out policy
instruments right now you've got to
imagine that nothing's happening and you
have a blank slate and you're your king
okay or Queen okay what would you do to
bring in policies that would be
effective really effective right away to
address the problems that you've all
talked about okay what would you do
forgetting about interests coalition's
what would be most effective right now
okay and then how might we actually go
about doing them okay now going to get
even more provocative though I'm going
to say and helmet you there for design
policies that would not have these
unintended effects but you've all talked
about okay so let's just take for
example the issue of a soil
certification now I work on forest
certification and I've
so spoke recently at the palm oil
certification Congress okay so here the
big issue is that there's a strong
concern that by focusing on practices of
different industries we might be
inadvertently contributing to wards
deforestation so the very sector that
end up deforesting for us soya and palm
end up getting certified for being
responsible and in fact arguably
legitimizing the deforestation in the
name of responsible stewardship okay now
the solution to this problem which
people do recognize is to say we have
cut off days at which point your land
could not be certified okay so it tends
to coincide with the creation of the
actual organization so yeah the Forest
Stewardship Council is cut off day at
which you can't certify for example
plantations forest plantations that were
converted from natural forests is 1993
now palm oils cutoff day in which you
can't certify palm oil if they were
converted from natural forests is 2006
and what's the cutoff date for a soya
okay fine so you can imagine this now so
if you're a company and you bought some
land there's no longer natural forest
but was and it was converted after 93
you got a lock for getting it forest
certified
ah but you can go to soy your palm
fantastic okay so you do that but now if
you're actually 2,000 and let's say
seven you can't do pomp ah but you can
just sell you so you do that right and
so it's a simply a game of actually
rewarding some types of degradation over
others and not addressing ongoing
problems of a deforestation for example
okay you know I just pick on sort of
occasion we like study at all okay and
how do we address these questions of
land use allocation versus practices the
actual practices and is there an
interaction between those that we want
to think about and finally in the food
security question is the problem
definition of food security
or is the problem definition local
livelihoods and getting a chance to be
part of the economic opportunities of a
sort of local market that's an important
question because we can imagine that
food security if it means like actually
protein and food for people's to be
produced by large-scale industrial
farming quite efficiently and
effectively that might actually reduce
pressures for deforestation that we
learned is often impacted by local
peoples so what is the actual problem
definition is that simply using food
security as a way to achieve another
problem which is local peoples being
involved in management so I'll stop
there but of the examples that I want to
raise and ask you then given all this
what would you actually want to do if
you could decide I really believe we
don't need to clear any more forests to
expand the production or to increase the
production of food or commodity for
instance in Brazil right now we have
around 2200 million hectares of pasture
very low intensity sometimes this is a
degraded pasture so when we think about
the Amazon that not have 9 million of
hectares that produce 8 percent of the
soy of the world and we think about we
have 200 million hectares of pasture we
really don't need to clear any more land
but the challenge is how do we address
the food production or the commodity
production to use those areas and not to
go to a forest area because the forest
area is cheaper then the area there is
already opening so how do what kind of
policies we can use for this and I think
one instrument that could be could be
interesting is the land-use planning but
how what is the land-use planning it
could be a ecological economic zoning
and we haven't it we have to take in
consideration like the limitations and
the suitability of the land and we have
to take in consideration the
stakeholders that are in this area but
we if we can develop
very comprehensive land use planning we
can really address the issue of food
security without converting any land
anymore but we have to need win for this
we need to have other types of public
policies now like what kind of
incentives to to convince the producers
to use this area that is already open it
ok thank you jack
I would not care about the local context
intent it was too short to explain but I
would not care about the local context
because there are 1 million local
contexts of millions peoples or maybe
thousand local context of thousands
locality so there is no way I can take
out the local context if I want to take
care of the local context I will get it
wrong because you cannot have you know
one PhD students in every village
looking at every single you know local
context there's no way so I would look
at the big picture and so the big
picture is you know those things that
apply basically everywhere you go
actually it's not so different even
maybe in mmm South America in Asia in
Africa so what's the big picture the big
picture is what one thing for example
well in the forest doesn't provide any
income it's a TV if it is worth nothing
I don't mean intrinsically I mean for
the livelihood of the people for the
economy in general well it would just be
good there's no reason people keep it so
let's put some value on the forest then
maybe you know we'll people will have an
incentive to keep it we're number two
the first is used people make their
livelihood out of it by doing shifting
cultivation going cassava so that value
I put on the forest has to go to those
same people if it goes to other people
then those who are using the forest they
will rebuild that will burn it they will
take revenge so every place I've been on
forests Fangio goes to rules apply so
concretely that that means what well
then I will buy a service I would say to
those people well you said cassava what
about selling a service which
consists of keeping that piece of waste
in place and I'll pay you as much as you
can get by you know making cassava out
of it now it's your choice you don't
want to do it you do cassava so as you
have the choice then I have to pay you
enough then we will see how much one
area I am ready to put on this forest
how much wolf I consider if it is it is
if I'm not ready to put as much money as
you get from the cassava then let's just
forget it that just means we don't care
about the forest with you know so for me
that's a marking approach that's a
carbon market but it's a market where
you know the the players in the market
are the same that are the player the
players today we are those farmers doing
shifting cultivation but in the red
currently the players are changing the
players were on the farmers now the
players are you know a few actors you
know who can make the intermediary
between you know the the government and
you and and some barriers around the
world yes that's correct
Jagannath and then we can come back for
okay I'll first go to your concern about
food security definition and then come
to others I mean I personally mean by
food security not only access
utilization stability or vulnerability
but but also the farmer I also pay
attention to the person who produce food
and the local livelihood local
environment so so it's I take it into a
border context for security right and
considering this problem of narrow
thinking about food security there is a
growing attention in the pal I'm sure it
is in other countries also to change it
to foot sir virginity so so so so
virginity sovereignty sovereignty sorry
so in fact Nepal's government policy is
not only on food security but so
virginity so if we read our Constitution
which has in
into and who related points so says that
40% Nathan Lane cover should be forest
lane area should be covered by forest we
should give a message on foot sir
virginity not on food security because
of the influence of bigger companies
coming out but somehow nepali still it's
not influenced by big companies the way
I see others context partly because it's
a small landlocked country surrounded by
India in China and so may be difficult
transport transport and some some of my
friends also give credit to the
political conflict that the foreign
investor haven't come to come to Nepal
for investing deforestation and other
thing that is a kind of a blazing
blessing in disguise that the conflict
didn't permit all these big companies to
come there and then on this issue of I
mean what I I mean I give due
consideration to local context right I
do is opposed to you because what we
have seen is giving consideration to
local context decentralization in terms
of forest management it has worked well
right because forestry oil centralized
forestry government Menace forest dint
work well and so we came back to this
I'm giving a lot of empowerment to local
people means that they know the local
context there are other local food they
don't a local genotype and they have
knowledge about the ecosystem so it
gives the chance for them to manage
their ecosystem where the forests are
land or past several other thing to
secure the latitude because lively it is
prime concern if the ecosystem doesn't
fulfil their livelihood
they weren't man is it that's for sure
right okay thank you did you have a yeah
it's a very quick comment it's like when
we take in consideration small holders
in Brazil
and if you want to pay them for instance
to protect the forest but we have to
compete with the opportunity cost of
soybean or they are leasing the Alliance
for soybean it's impossible there is no
money to conserve the amount of forest
that we have and to compete with the
opportunity cost of soybeans so how do
we how do you think to tackle this
actually do
I can't wait but I want Jack to respond
to first yeah so I guess opportunity
cost has to be considered within the
policy frame which has to be broadened
well then what happens just on that
locality so I mean if you consider
opportunity cost is you know how much
you'll all you lose by not growing so
being in that place and soybean is going
to result in thousands of etc of dollars
per hectare I don't know how much but a
lot of money ok well then of course you
cannot match that but maybe there are
other places you can also bean so if you
look at the economy at the national
scale and not only the business plan of
that farmer then opportunity cost might
be the difference between growing
soybean in a place which is not the
first place but which is maybe some land
which is not with intensively cultivated
or that some landlord is about
neglecting a little bit so shifting the
production from the forest to those
places results in a lower open
opportunity cost than the one you would
calculate just based on the business
plan of that farmer now how to get that
farmer who wanted to invest there I
agree it's is not easy it's complicated
and and I think also that with the
Oconee cost approach that also means
that you cannot stop deforestation
everywhere and that the state also has
some negativity to to do what oh well
have done before in Europe we finished
to clear our forests in the middle age
and in America maybe 200 years ago and
all those countries covered by huge huge
tract of forest they want to have also
back on
be part of the same history so that
means that in place where the
opportunity cause it's super high maybe
that means or pseudo space okay let's do
agriculture there but try to do it in a
nice way or at least keeping you know
something some product that I arrive to
keep some pieces of those ecosystems I
just wanna make an observation they will
open it up for broader questions so I
really enjoyed your responses and there
really are a couple of themes that came
out there are also very much in the
broader literature on these questions
and so when there's the policy
instrument and so we've heard land use
is key which is often seen as sort of a
top-down central government approach
we've heard about local land use
governance being the key and you've
heard about sort of market mechanisms
and incentives being something to think
about but then we thought about actual
problems we've heard different problems
from deforestation to livelihoods etc
and to me the big challenge is one
linking the instruments to the problems
we care about so right now I would argue
that the tail is wagging the dog okay
which means that we really focus now on
incentive based approaches red soya
certification for certification and so
on and often are not achieving the
results we want because we end up
believing in the instrument and not the
actual problem and that has to get
reversed and that's a big problem now
because we assume these things are the
way to go markets argued businesses
argued they could be good but we must be
more careful linking to the actual
results we care about and I would argue
therefore the big problem that we have
on forests governance including the
questions you're talking about is the
need to distinguish whether we're
talking about some kind of practice be
at local livelihoods be a palmela
certification and then designation of
the broader landscape according to
different practices because the reality
is that markets be the rubber or soils
will determine the actual use unless we
do have some kind of top-down approach
for allocating these things the
challenge is then well what about local
governance
another argue that
problem is that it's not a simple
dichotomy of central versus a local so
for example where we do see successful
and by that I mean broad support I don't
necessarily mean the best examples of
broad land use allocations New Zealand
British Columbia and so on have been
with a government the national or
provincial government said here is what
you must do you must protect 12% of the
land base from extraction you must do
these things but then you local peoples
decide how to do it and if you don't do
get an agreement we will then impose it
on you this is an amazing technique so
it's in between a central and local and
the local peoples from the mining sector
to for a second or two First Nations
realize they know the self-interest in
actually agreeing to broader strategies
because if not there's a worry of
getting a worse outcome by the be
imposed and then the solution is quite
legitimate and then it's widely
supported from there you can discuss
practices and how to be better stewards
but my concern is we're focusing on the
practices and and forgetting what the
broader questions of allocation and
resources and that least of the question
is Brazil's Amazon's 25 percent
protected area enough maybe it is enough
if you say that actually is pretty good
and the question is how do we maintain
that or do we say no it's the Amazon it
should be half and then how do we have
that kind of conversation yeah yeah and
the instruments I was amazed I was a you
know what climate party
few weeks ago in Washington and you know
there was a lot of people involved in
climate policies and having done an
international career and then you know
you go around you have some snacks a
drink and you chat with people and what
really struck me is that the locale was
absent who everybody was talking about
very sophisticated instruments everybody
was very smart very brilliant people
young people committed but the locale
was absent so you might think I'm
contradicting myself because I said I
don't care about the locale no it's a
seminar you're allowed to know
I think I don't I mean the problem is
that the locale is ignored but even for
its basics because the local there are
some commonalities in the local register
that any place you go any local place
you go is just the same for example I
mentioned yield does it matter in
shifting cultivation around the world
yes not the main criteria for the
farmers so that's something local but
it's not contextual it's really
generally so this kind of thing are
neglected and then we focus on the
instrument and the instrument I have a
very quick comment about the definition
what is enough or not because we don't
have all these answers and if we have to
think right now we would say that's too
late so that's a discussion that we I
was having with generals the other day
so we cannot give us this
we cannot allow ourself to think that we
still can keep the first day eating or
tear in some land so I don't know it's
just maybe half of the Amazon is
sufficient I don't know maybe not I
think we are but my point is we should
have an idea as to what we actually want
to achieve before we start having
instruments being chosen
I mean Kaz mania has 46 percent of its
land base in protected areas forty six
or seven percent which is very high but
it's also until recently being
deforesting okayed de plantations for
pulp mills so depending on your problem
definition this is a really great story
or a really bad story
and if you decide beforehand about these
land use allocation systems you've got
some kind of context to make that choice
versus simply grabbing on to the latest
instrument and not really knowing where
you're going okay now we should we
should open it up though I think I fully
agree even though we didn't know much
about it the best practices I mean among
the practices I know from their impacts
and when we consider best practices so
that shows that border a very broad goal
is important in terms of what we want
and that has to be fixed not by top-down
approach but by communication between
local and central have whatever it is
that has to be a communication otherwise
you see the the local context and local
people would not agree on what has been
imposed upon so that could be that could
backfire and in in South Asia I think in
some in some sense they have we started
doing this like Nepal we want 40 percent
of the land area forests written in the
Constitution
Booton it is written in the Constitution
that 60 percent after line area of the
country should have it the forest these
are broad goals and based on the
scientists and people they have done it
and when broad categories of land-use
ISM is important and we have realizing
in Nepal we are realizing that we did
have land-use categories for the
agriculture land were to build Road and
were to build settlement and things like
that so very best agricultural land had
been destroyed because at least cashman
know is a most fertile land in the
Muslim in the world because it was a
kind of a lake for many many years and
so the soil I mean farmers used to dig
soil down to get the fertile soil up so
that was a practice but it has all been
settled fully and then all this then
hasn't been used properly and now people
feel that we should have a kind of broad
categories of land where to build
settlement were to build Road and were
to be practiced
yeah that's ok and that's for you a good
approach but is that a good idea yeah
that should be that's good in in in
forestry and protected areas and broad
categories have been made yeah I know
that because we had a little park and we
had people living near Roy and then we
felt that one more category is needed
where people can can use the natural
resources like forest and so they
develop buffer zone in between yeah okay
so what Rajan people can depend on
buffer zone but protecting so nowadays
there is person in a very National Park
okay so I think it's Sudan okay great
now we're gonna open it up now for
questions okay over here oh and this one
isn't thanks for um this discussion it's
been really interesting so we've been
talking a lot of this conference about
integrating agriculture and food systems
with forests and I'm wondering a lot of
these systems by their nature are
diverse and kind of hard to measure
quantify and so I'm wondering if you can
comment on how to make these multi use
areas more legible to whether it's
market incentives certification red
planning or like a top-down landscape
allocation approaches and whether like
the diversity of these systems makes
that more difficult and how you would
kind of deal with that okay so look at
people they combine those things that's
clear I mean shifting cultivation is
really it's a forest agricultural system
as soon as you leave the land the
forestry goals people mix you know
picking up products I mean what we call
non-timber forest products are quite
often harvested in in fields or in
fellows so it's really a combination now
we have some policies there are some
outcome from those system some services
we want those services to be provided
because at global scale we consider that
this has some value and maybe at global
scale we recognize more value than we
look at people recognized for some
features or some services of those
systems so then we can pull some strings
we can play a little bit with the system
and that's when we do in any policy when
we put taxes or incentives so when
something you know is good for the for
the community but not good for the
individual then we put a subsidy so it
becomes better for the individual and
then the community will benefit
otherwise than if we do not do it for
example we want more less for us to be
cleared then we put some value on the
forest red we can call that a subsidy
it's market-based approach but we could
also call it a Suzy we just don't use
the wall because if you put subsidy you
know in a in a grant application or in a
policy documents people we bar in red
you know you must not use that word but
it's a subsidy actually and and then
people are going to react to that so
yeah to clarify something when I said
that I don't care about the local
context that doesn't mean that the local
context doesn't matter it matters a lot
but that's precisely because it matters
that I don't care about it because I
leave it to the people they know their
local context very well so this is
actually what you were suggesting you
know you what you want mentioning about
abroad you create an incentive and then
people are going to find their own
solution and so they will appropriate
they will find a white way to intensify
the system keeping more forests because
they will be the incentive of the
payment coming from the subsidy off on
the carbon market let's take a few more
questions so we can not just put here
back over here and then over here oh I
actually wanted to add to that because
it is on but it's on can you hear me
okay
I actually wanted to address that
question because when I work was working
at the world like or forestry Center we
I was trying to think of the the dilemma
of certification being only for one
product but yet you want to protect a
whole landscape so how do you do that
one model that we looked at was Apple s
young which does focus on one product
but it also focuses on the whole terroir
and it focuses on the savoir faire of
the producers so there is a whole sort
of cultural dimension of epaulettes
young so could you take that principle
and play it more generally and so I came
up with this idea of high-value
agroforestry zones that would produce a
number of products that could receive
some kind of sort of landscape
certification that would take the savoir
faire the cultural element into into
account that would that is the local
that I think is absolutely critical you
know for maintaining the goods and
services the diverse amount a number of
goods and services on a landscape so
nothing ever came of that concept note
but if anybody's interested in pursuing
that that that line I'd be interested in
discussing it okay just take two more
questions I think the problem about
deforestation is when talking about
deforestation we should also consider
the context of leakages and the leakages
can be national or local but can also be
international you may reduce
deforestation in Brazil because you
don't need people to cut forest again
but if in Peru they there is no that
same system so you you are increasing
deforestation in Peru so how do we how
do you think we can address the leakages
problem in local national or
international
responses one if we're talking about
global or larger frameworks versus local
solutions and you're talking I mean I
find your comments on instrument and the
pushing of the instrument and the
priority of the instrument very
interesting in if it's about language
and it's about interpretation of local
systems into larger languages and
translation to and from if instruments
such as ecosystem services are created
in an institutional scale there's a
corollary to that in current forms of
rethinking economic policy and economics
where there's a focus on local currency
is there an opportunity for something
like a local framework for ecosystem
services and is it important to create a
global currency or is it more important
to have a local currency or there's
maybe less velocity in the system
overall but more opportunities for
translation and more languages that at
work my comment is about the the issue
that you brought us what is going on in
Brazil right now it's a new initiative
what they call the jurisdictional
certification or a zero jurisdictional
zero deforestation so instead of just
looking for soy you're just looking for
soy certification or timber
certification how we can get a
compromise from the home municipality or
it can be a basin or it could be a
region or even a region so we get the
commitment of all stakeholders and for a
zero deforestation or we take the whole
area as a I don't know very hazardous
chemicals free zone or outdoor GMO free
zone and we can really tackle all the
the problems at the same point and this
kid cannot I can can lead to avoid
leakage as well what is happening right
now that's interesting as well in Brazil
like when a
I mean once you expand even if it's over
pasture we have to be sure that the keto
that was in this pasture is not going to
the forest so what they are going what
they are developing right now is a
deforestation free certificate and the
soy producer pays a little bit for the
certificate to guarantee that this keto
is not going to a forest and this money
goes for a cattle prod producers to help
them to intensify their production or to
get technical assistance so we can avoid
the leakage and taking in consideration
a whole area so this could be another
initiative I know and but it could be a
solution and one point that I think that
sometimes we are missing is that we have
to take in consideration like
macroeconomics
like if we really think in the Amazon
right now in Brazil the second-biggest
oil reserve in Brazil is under the
Amazon estate isn't the core of the
Amazon and we have several dams besides
Belo Monte and like in the Tapatio River
Basin we have more than 200 dams that is
been playing so how is this gonna affect
deforestation and I think the major
driver is not agriculture anymore but
how other countries and this is
expanding for the whole basin so
Brazilian development pain bank is
investing in Peru in Ecuador in Bolivia
and so how do we convince our economic
ministers that you conserve is also to
conserve the forest is also very
important
well the the context I have experienced
a lot it's quite different than Brazil
and where big industries have a role but
when when you talked about leakages it
immediately came to my mind about the
local level leakages that taken place
what I've seen is I mean there was
community forestry now that has given to
a community and they have won that and
they have considered that that's their
one and you know that give put a less
pressure on the community forestry they
have given more pressure on the
government first so slight degradation
on government forests took place so it
is very local level of leakages but the
human behavior may be similar when you
take into context and how to address
this is again again because government
was the state is the ward of the
government forest but it wasn't there to
look after it
and when that somewhat degraded forest
was given to another community for
management so they looked after it so do
I store so I think if we can give this
stewardship to the people who who use it
I think we can avoid this leakage
problem but I'm talking of a very local
context the international players might
play a different game and it would be a
different context yeah and then I think
on this ecological service I have one
experience and it's based on my
experience and based on Nepal so at one
time we had planned to have a ecosystem
service for water for Kathmandu because
it comes from one National National Park
so we had a kind of a proposed policy to
give to give incentive to the local
people there in the
so that they can preserve a water and do
not pollute it I'm trying to get access
to good water but a somewhat it didn't
come in to implement implementation and
and then in the discussions a different
opinion kim ein the opinion was that
when we just emphasize water then it
might have some influence they are like
they would have more ponds in the in the
region and I know if it is not preserved
properly then it might lead to land
degradation erosion and another thing so
so emphasizing one product for ecosystem
service could lead to some problem
that's what I guessed
yeah to answer the briefly the question
so I like the idea of society
subsidizing agroforestry landscape and
also you get to the idea of subsidizing
you can have many many image native
ideas but the the problem is that it's a
it's a political challenge to phase out
subsidies in a rich countries in spite
of the fact we know they have perverse
effect but it's the same political
challenge to even talk about subsidies
when it's about developing countries so
that's I think the problem that has to
be solved but as the carbon price goes
down maybe carbon fund will actually
more and more have to rely on public
fund if there are no barriers and 4-d
cage
I think there's no way you can formally
anticipate leakage calculate how much
leakage where and when I think there's
no way you can do that the only thing
you can do is make assumption about
whole overhaul reduce the cage and maybe
the more the more value you put on the
force by subsidizing it and the more you
can expect so force will remain in place
even if you don't know exactly where and
how and there's also the problem of the
demand as long as there will be the same
demand for forest products for log
or land well you will have this how did
you call it that game yeah you will have
leakages actually were camera stuff now
if you reduce the demand or if you
satisfy more certification less demand
less demand for land by moving to area
which has already been deforested to to
make extensive soybean cultivation
then you also will reduce the cage
because you will read just demand
just a quick rejoinder which is you
should actually Google whack-a-mole and
just watch it visually it really doesn't
actually symbolize the the challenges
that we face and in forest governance in
the fun way actually now the but Jacques
I do you want to come back to a point
you just made which is that again the
instruments you were talking about were
some kind of economic instrument
subsidies and so on and we've seen to
lost this idea that we also connect you
to designate land and so you can't do
things there regardless of the cost and
actually many advocate privatization is
a way of improving management when we
know that by doing that you often lose
biodiversity and other resources and
impacts that if you want to go back and
achieve later you must then pay those
new owners for but if the land hadn't
been privatized in the first place it
wouldn't even be an issue so the broader
context in which we think about
instrument choice here that were often
forgetting again by going to the weeds
and looking at market mechanisms and not
standing back and asking what is it we
want to achieve and I would encourage
this conference on all you do first ask
the questions what do we want to achieve
and then what are the mechanisms that
best help us achieve that versus the
tail wagging the dog or the whack-a-mole
problem occurring but let me thank join
me in thanking our three panelists for a
really fantastic discussion and set of
presentations about the importance other
details and these broader questions
I also wanted to say I know you have a
chance again but I do want to really
thank our students in the school put on
a fantastic conference I've been working
with Karen Peterson and Daisy hey Lopez
but there's a bunch more as well so I
think they all know who you are but you
guys can just stand up for one second
the students should be involved in the
conference if you could just all stand
up thank you we are really proud of our
students so thank you very much for all
you do for the school and for the planet
okay now we're having a break and you
come back and I think 15 minutes is that
right
you
community
or the photo competition this year there
were two phases in this photo
competition in which we first got a
submission of 48 photos that were first
uploaded to the is TF Facebook page for
the Yale FBS community to choose their
favorite five-fold five favorite photos
online to put their likes on it and then
the second phase was this during this
conference in which 16 photos with the
highest numbers of votes were selected
to be shown during the conference and
then votes were submitted to determine
the top three photos okay the winners
are going to receive a coupon for
groumet foods at NICUs and we thank them
for supporting us it with this
competition and the winners are
third place insect on branch by David a
merman
the second-place year by l'a WA by Karen
Peterson the head of this is EF
conference and the first place their big
favorite sky journalist by Liam s now we
would like to give the word - we also
liked so now we would like to invite
mark Bradford a Bompard the director of
the Yale sustainable food project to
invite the panels for the next
discussion mark you
thanks very much I I suppose that means
I invite the panelists for the next
discussion based on that prompt if I'm
happy actually the names I printed here
on both sides helpful for everybody
involved um if you see your name up here
please join me at the front table and I
will provide a better introduction and
we can start the scintillating
discussion
is the lapel mic working at this point
excellent thank you everybody very much
it's a being very good to chat with you
in and out of this conference over the
last couple days and I know the thanks
of being given again and again to the
organizers but I will just reiterate one
more time how thrilled I've been to be
working with the students who put this
conference on and how much it's made me
appreciate how fortunate I am to be
working at this institution just because
of the quality of the students our
guests the discussion the ideas and all
of the projects which they are going to
launch and it is with that goal to
synthesize some wonderful ideas and
launch some wonderful collaborations and
projects that we wanted to tie this
final panel together with ten ten of you
almost nine I don't know if it qualifies
as a panel per se my goodness there's a
lot of you and it does mean that as we
introduce the topics that will be there
for discussion we won't be proceeding
with everyone taking a shot at it more I
would like to introduce a couple
questions that are actually based on the
quandaries from the introductory keynote
and then we're going to move in to some
questions that are asking more about
what the next collaborative steps can be
I'd like to keep things to about 15-20
minutes for the first introduction of
quandaries and discussion of those and
so you are going to have to be a little
bit self moderating just because the
gestures that can actually be seen by
all of you are going to be you know
violent by the time they make it down to
the end little line so please consider
whether you're able to keep your
statement to about one minute when it
comes to the quandaries and then we'll
quickly shift on to the next I have met
some of you I'm just going to introduce
Jonah Diane Sarah Karen do we have it
all in order here so far
so Jacque oh I need to put you on this
junk Jagannath and Peter Selena and
Betsy so I've seen some of your work
over the last couple days but not all of
it so we're going to get some new
tidbits out as well I wanted to bring us
back to that introductory keynote when
Francis gave a speech brought some ideas
to the forefront and offered for
quandaries now we've had a lot of
discussion since introducing those four
quandry so well I will real quaint you
with them we're actually going to
combine some of them and add a little
bit to the quandary as our first
discussion points so the four quandary
is work first of all one how should we
frame the forest and food security issue
when communicating with various
audiences the second one is should we
dismantle the barriers between the
forestry world and the agriculture world
and talk only about landscapes the third
very appropriate to the last discussion
how do we design market and governance
mechanisms to protect forests that
respect local rights and give weight to
legitimate food security concerns at
different scales and then finally given
the multiple challenges of mobilizing
and the urgency of mobilizing how do we
actually focus our efforts now as I said
we're going to tweak this a little bit
and the first thing that I would like to
invite feedback on from the panel is a
little bit of a combination of the first
two quandary
because when you're asking about framing
and when you're asking about dismantling
barriers you're into the very similar
themes of strategic communications' of
the issue strategic alliances that you
may either want to build in some cases I
think there was the insinuation that a
strategic division could be a useful
effort so in this question about framing
and how you state who you are who your
audiences are who the stakeholders are
who you're working for or what the
objectives are I know small topic I'm
wondering if I can turn it over to the
whole panel and if anyone is bold to be
to say what you found over the
discussions of the last day and a half
that most influenced your view of a new
way of framing and communicating this
issue strategically and then we'll take
three or four comments and move into the
next synthesized question
and as a prompt you can also take from
any of the panels you attended over the
last two days perhaps the most inspiring
framing situation that you learned about
as a case study from someone else's work
I actually think today was really
interesting with Jacques presentation um
in framing and thinking about the
question in the back I'm sorry I forget
your name and the yellow sweater but
Julia and asking how can and this is in
relation to forests and food security
actually is how can shift in cultivation
what Jacques you are doing I think is
really interesting how can that be made
legible to forest carbon markets right
and so my question more is that we I
think your question wasn't exactly
answered and I think it's an important
one to think about is that how can those
kinds of complex interrelationships in
forests be made legible to these carbon
markets so that their rights are secured
to food and their livelihoods while at
the same time we have this global agenda
for carbon forestry and I guess anyone
can answer that's what I think is really
interesting I would like to just quickly
on unframed I know one of the the
speakers on food security started out
saying what do we think of a food and
also to back up the other side and say
what is a forest when we're talking
about a forest and frame it with our
understanding of how we all see forests
and maybe how to work with that that may
be this idea that people have of a
pristine forest is imaginary to begin
with and how can we reconsider idea of
what forest could be or should be or
what they are and also to remind people
that are really pro conservation of
forest that they also eat food and that
food comes from somewhere as well
and I always say something also about
the framing
I will be cautious about the the world
and the concept of framing maybe there
is too much framing maybe that's the
problem I mean when you do a PhD and I
guess it's the adventure that we all
have or did have here also soon we'll
have but when we do a PhD there's always
that we expectation that we frame our
subject that we use a given a data
analytical conceptual frame some methods
on Theory excetera but when you are
living you're facing problem you want to
solve the problem you are involved in
your life what will framing mean in that
concept I mean and and we just trying to
solve the problem picking up everything
that we think you know in an
opportunistic way can help to solve that
problem and if we frame isn't there a
risk that maybe some solution that is
going to passing around we we just miss
it because it's not in the frame so when
I did a PhD I asked a question how to
stop deforestation in Madagascar without
a ski requiring the marginalize or the
poorest people to play the price for it
that's it I mean I don't know if that's
what you mean by framing in the sense of
asking a very specific question or if it
is more than that and if it is more than
that I think we really have to be
cautious about that well when I think
about this gets to the audience to and
our and the focus so see we talk about
food and we talk about forests so where
are the people in that where are the
institutions where the rural communities
why you know where are the territories I
mentioned the word terroir which is one
of my favorite words you know where is
the not just the market incentives or
policy incentives but sort of cultural
incentives to maintain a landscape I had
issues with landscape when it first came
out because it doesn't really convey a
human territory you know
and I think if we don't have human
territories and people who will sustain
those human territories it doesn't
matter what kind of because the
incentives are never going to be enough
the market incentives of the policy
incentives I don't think are ever going
to be enough to to make that happen
maybe we can talk a little bit later
about what it would take to keep people
you know to provide that sort of
holistic approach to keeping people and
valuing a territory whether it be for
well multiple multiple uses and services
I think coming back from what Professor
cash were mentioned like what do we want
to achieve and when we frame we have to
be very clear that we want to achieve
for its conservation and at the same
time food production so how can we I
would say that we have to talk with the
decision-makers especially taking in
consideration macroeconomics decisions
and how is how FAR's is important to
keep not only the commodity production
but as well as the food that is coming
to our plates every day now and we have
to provide some incentives for those
people who are really producing those
this kind of food
what what I think is the problem in
linking forests to food security also
lies in our understanding of
biodiversity and a lot of contentions
comes from mmm comes from the kind of
thinking about biodiversity and
understanding different actors
perspective on biodiversity for example
forestry people agricultural people find
the users who use the forest
it could be shifting cultivators it
could be peasant farmers like in the
pole because they have different
perspective on biodiversity because of
this I think there is contentions among
the actors in terms of conserving
biodiversity so I think some some
discussion on understanding biodiversity
from people's perspective would be also
very much important so if this happens I
think there is any scope to increase
food security from forestry that's what
I feel well maybe give an example is
something that I think is is an
unproductive but common frame which is
either/or between conservation and
production and so questions come up that
I hear often something like you know the
the palm oil industry is a multi tens of
billions of dollar industry in Indonesia
the soy industry multi tens of billions
of dollars in in Brazil how can we ever
stop that with our small pots of money
for environment and I think that that
really leads quickly to despair because
the answer is of course you can't stop
it and really when you think about it
you wouldn't want to stop it you
wouldn't want to stop soy production but
a much more helpful frame as is marginal
thinking at the margin it's about
reconciling two very important goals of
food security
and climate and then you think about red
you're not stopping palm oil
you're not even stopping deforestation
from palm oil you're trying to reduce
deforestation from palm oil and so then
you start thinking well what if we
instead of stopping all palm oil
everywhere you have places where you
would have maybe a district thinking
about 50% deforestation instead they do
25% that's a big gain for the climate
and some of that palm oil production
could be produced elsewhere you just
open up your mind to many more solutions
yes one of the I guess one of the points
that stuck with me from I guess I think
I think only shouting was the one to
sort of explicitly mention wastage as a
component of this sort of food forest
system that we don't think enough about
and the sense that so much of what we
currently do is so inefficient and and
characters to know as well I mean
talking about the possibilities for
increasing production without removing
any more forests just through more
efficient use of what's already there in
terms of pasture land in Brazil and
there's a huge amount of degraded land
in in Indonesia that can be more it is
more suitable for palm oil or cattle
this suitable for palm oil and would
have obviously less environmental impact
than then cutting more climber forests
and and then just the current
distribution of the food that we
currently produce and how much of that
is is wasted in this thrown away it
never reaches the table I think there's
a lot of increased efficiency that we
could do about what we eat and how we
distribute it and that is a big part of
this picture the paps we don't talk
enough about so we don't know because
yes I just wanted to share a framework
that came up out of our discussion
yesterday on the integration of forests
and nutrition and if such a framework
was viable so when we think about
framing I think it's important to think
about creating frameworks for different
audiences and perhaps for a policy
audience one of
frameworks that sort of came out of the
discussion yesterday was I framing it in
a crisis sort of situation could perhaps
be effective so looking at more of it as
a defense like a national defense issue
maybe one way to go maybe just to
synthesize on that question the idea of
crisis framing as a strategic
communications objective almost how do
you market something so nuanced complex
and what you're pushing forward is not a
soundbite capturable objective so is
there value in using some kind of crisis
framing for strategic policy objectives
maybe I'll just put that out to the
thoughts of the panel we talked about
the power of both from Selina the idea
of national security national integrity
sovereignty issues and also in that
panel there was some discussion about
the overwhelmingly compelling power of
the feeding 9-billion idea and how it
has overwhelmed many other policy
directions being taken along for that
particular ill-defined goal so given
that given the imperfection of it but
the incredibly compelling power from a
policy arena that some of these crisis
framings have is this a direction which
is valuable to go in yes oh he's
speaking off-the-record I guess on that
on that issue when the food crisis came
out and our agency responded I think
there there was an immediate thought to
jump into staple food crops and
increased production of staple food
crops and because it was framed as a
crisis a kind of the OL these mindsets
you know crept back in that we just need
to produce more food even though we've
known for you know decades that that's
really not what food food security is
about well I wanted to mention that for
me the framing of food security as being
not just about producing more food but
about quality of food and diversity of
food was really really key but there's
been a rethinking the
we just came out as an agency we just
came out with a resilient strategy and
one reason of that was stepping back a
little bit from the whole like we just
have to produce more food to looking at
places like this hell or and you know
the Horn of Africa they're fragile and
you know if you just try to produce more
food it's it's going to you know risk
damaging ecosystems or it was just not
even going to be feasible and you have
to really stop focusing more on the
humanitarian and much more on the
longer-term drivers of food insecurity
so I think the crisis mentality is
probably not the best way to frame those
issues because it just it tends to drive
shorter term responses I agree with
Diane and I think that for instance when
we use the severe drought that happened
in the u.s. last summer and the whole
media in the whole world put a lot of
attention on this and this leads to an
increase of production in Brazil so an
increase of soy production and other
crops so and these could have lead to
more deforestation and other impacts as
well so we have to be very careful when
we think about bring Gina crisis I think
at some point it can help but nowadays I
believe that communications in the whole
world can affect what what happens here
can affect there and we have to be very
cautious how we frame and what are these
responses for these crises we cannot
only incentivize the rise of production
or the increase of production because
this could lead to other problems as
well yeah I think in some way the right
framing for an issue emails naturally if
you have the right approach I mean what
I mean is that there is something I
don't use a lot of statistics or a lot
of competitive in my in my research but
there's something I always want to
measure
I hope I will miss weight someday that's
the correlation between the number of
days or weeks or month that a person an
expert a read expert or a food security
expert or sustainable developments
expelled spans in a village in the
village we are living the people who are
actually shaping the world shaping the
countryside shaping the forest shaping
the farming system shaping the food
production system and to correlate that
with their framing of the idea they have
about how to solve those problems and I
think your correlation would be huge so
when I when I said that there's a
natural framing that cool image I think
that if if every person involved in a
read debate will have actually spent six
month in the village where are living
the people who are actually going to
determine the fate of the forest in the
future I think there would be a
consensus that emerges and there will be
the right framing that emerges and we
could say the same thing for many other
issues the problem is that it doesn't
happen most you know expect that we are
you know we have to struggle to
negotiate event for with any institution
we work with to actually spend some time
doing field work and really interacting
closely with the people I
I remember thinking many times if only
it was a requirement that policymakers
were required to make a living off of
farming for one year of their lives one
season it would change the framing quite
significantly I do want to shift gears
though a little bit to the third
question that was asked at the beginning
and it's very relevant to pick up on the
discussion that was happening this
morning about scale of governance about
the locally adaptive and responsive
policies and the problem that the the
whack-a-mole problem I'm just happy that
I got a chance to use that phrase again
when you have a well-developed
context specific local policy strategy
applied and the problem just pops up in
some other jurisdiction in the absence
of a larger
régime so I wanted to ask you some of
the thoughts that came up about
strategies for achieving the kind of
joined-up policy strategies that would
be necessary to have the locally
responsive policies not just fall prey
to whack-a-mole of having the problem
pop up in another jurisdiction again
glad you asked this question there's
since the beginning of red as a thing
this has always been one of the
questions and so it's been answered from
the beginning with a number of important
design features so one is read as a
national policy intervention that
emission reductions from deforestation
are measured and compensated at the
level of an entire country rather than a
project site or a village and by making
an IRR that incentivizes governments to
make interventions at policy reforms at
a level that are simply beyond the scope
and mandate of individual villages and
by doing so control leakage or if we
catch happens it's not it's deducted
from the compensation that's that's
heading to those countries so that's
probably the most important feature of
read for for controlling leakage the
second in the international negotiations
the International issue is the issue of
broad participation so you have some
countries with rapid deforestation lots
of emissions loss you know Brazil
Indonesia the biggest - and then others
whereas you have some other countries
that have large areas of forest but as
up till the present have been pretty
good in maintaining very low rates of
deforestation in the Congo Basin and the
Guyana Shield and so it's very important
that these country the countries of
these regions are incentivized to
participate in a red system as well and
this pot this probably means a structure
of incentives that looks a little bit
different from payments for reducing
deforestation it probably means payments
for maintaining deforestation and extra
Leeloo present rate um just to add on
the question of scale which i think is a
great question to not only look at
spacial scales but temporal scales and
especially when we're talking about
agroforestry and trees trees are trees
they grow very slowly so I think if I
answered Diane's question if you had the
elevator speech one recommendation to
help collaborations in these projects
develop that I would have us go through
a document whenever you see a time frame
put by an aid agency at a zero on the
end of it and and and also along with
that the that successes don't happen all
or nothing and to get get beyond an idea
that it's either failed or succeeded and
see that that you could have some things
work and some things not with the whack
Amole so it's always you're always
trying to move forward but to know that
it's not going to all happen the first
the first try
well we know that particularly in Africa
that still the vast majority of forests
are still owned and managed by the state
and we also know that without local
community ownership or buy-in to forest
management it's probably not going to be
effective so that's a that's a big
challenge that governments have to face
and they have to face it at the national
level they have to there has to be
tenure reform and has to be done
sensitively and but not overly complex
ly as we've learned over many years in
community forestry you start out with
these complex systems and then you know
they don't work and then you have to
simplify so that's something we could
get started with right away and
encourage countries to just do it
did anybody learn any inspiring examples
or workable examples
the non-state mechanisms for achieving
some of these policy objectives in the
discussions of the last day I talked
about them so I'm a very I believe from
the M&I I really believe that the
private sector can play a very important
role not only on to stop reducing
deforestation and leading to issues with
food security and we can mention for
instance for the small holders for the
very remote areas in the Amazon the
state sometimes cannot reach them but
the companies or some companies are
there selling their products or a
technical assistance so we need or we
could develop some public/private
partnership so the companies can help
the local government local
municipalities or the state government
to get on those very remote areas so I
think there is a huge space for us to
develop more commitments or more
dialogue with with the private sector
yeah forward in Congo they are
profitable a toast yeah at least three
project run by private companies
including one that we visited and so I
think those part up operators can really
play a great role if they are working in
the right boundaries in the right rules
so of course there's the the
responsibility of the government and
other stakeholders partnering with the
government to define those rules for
example the committee National Red now
is creating a tool which would be online
where every private project will
register so what they do what are they
propose their methods will be
transparent so that's a way to help you
know granting that those part operators
will do something that's good for the
public and there is also something very
interesting in those in this web project
that we visited it's actually the it's
the fact that the
the the head of the private companies
that is at least the subsidiary that is
based in Congo is a Congolese who
originated from the era where the red
project is implemented and he really has
a commitment to do something for his
community for his region because he
upsells that there's just no state the
state is not there that since the 80s
everything collapse and so someone helps
some of the organization have to take
over the state and this is why he wants
the the red project to really contribute
or so to bridge schools to build health
center and in the in the communist
country and that's something that I fail
to see reading all the documents about
the another red project which also has
behind him a personality who originated
from the area where the red project well
it may be it was not a red project it
was a carbon sequestration the EB but
the key and here also there is someone
who originated from a region and then
designed this project and get carbon
payments and those two person they seem
to have an idea of commitment to the
community which we can which makes me
think to the concept of the moral
economy so they are leader they are
making business there are actually from
family of Chiefs but they want to find
some way to redistribute the benefit to
to the world community so there are like
playing the game of the state at the
scale of the other community and other
region so it's quite an interesting
process to look at I just wanted to
mention that we we referred to state and
private sector I think we should also
look into the role of civil society
civil society in the sense like I
include NGOs Federation's of people who
manage resources so in my context it is
like we call it the Kofun federation of
community forestry
groups which can play a strong role to
preserve the rights of the user groups
Forest Whitaker's and experience that
organizing these users in in such such a
way empowers the users of the forestry
they can they can negotiate with the
state that power has come from that so
role of civil society is also important
it could be different in different
context the discussion about I think
broadening the scope to make sure that
we've got perhaps a non-traditional
stakeholders represented in the
processes that we're building some
strange coalition's perhaps between the
public private voluntary civil society
sectors that will lead me to the first
part of the last question where I'm
going to ask if there are any
collaborations that we should be
embarking on groups that we should be
inviting to work together who previously
have been working separately and I do
want to compliment the organizers of
this conference for bringing some of the
people on the agricultural side of the
table for bringing someone like me into
this discussion it has it's been
something that we haven't really done
before in the work that I've been doing
the divisions have remained quite solid
and so this is a wonderful start
but I'm thinking beyond the food neg
people and the forestry conservation
people are there particular stakeholder
groups that would be really beneficial
to bring into the discussion and to
begin collaboration with perhaps in this
conference I'm really concerned about
what is going on for instance in Brazil
right now I think I mentioned this
before like the major threat right now
it's infrastructure projects and we have
to start talking to the Brazilian
Development Bank and we have to start
talking with The Economist's and the
people who are just building
infrastructure like dams and or maybe
releasing the oil projects and
and rolled construction so because they
are making this these decisions they
have a lot of money a lot of power and I
don't think they realize or they do not
sometimes they do not know all the other
issues that we are bringing as for
conserving the forests or for increasing
food production so we really need to
talk with with the people who are who
are the economic drivers of the of those
countries of those economies and maybe
at a smaller scale we have actors that
are invisible but very powerful in the
economy like chainsaw loggers artisanal
loggers artisanal miners bush meat
hunters when we had the Liberia forest
dialogue we invited some of those folks
to come and talk to big private sector
government officials donors and it was
instructive because then these are
people who make their livelihoods but as
I say they're invisible on the policy
angle and their their value isn't
captured either by communities or by the
state and if we can find a way to
somehow bring them into the picture
a we could everyone would benefit I'd
like to talk about a little bit about an
example from Colombia it wasn't
something that came up in this weekend
but it's about collaboration and it's
about the role of non-state actors in
your last question and you know I I
think the reason we tend to or really
should tend to think first about the
state actors in this problem is because
the state is a great way to solve a
collection a collective action problem
and if you don't have someone doing that
it's difficult to ask individual farmers
to to turn aside from practices which
are generating market income for them to
something which is providing a global
good but for which they receive no
compensation so States can solve that
problem I was in Colombia a few months
ago and
talking to the the head of research in
the Colombian Ministry of Environment
and she said that their plan was to work
very closely with the association of
cattle ranchers in their country to
provide incentives and and and policy
inducements for them to reduce their
emissions as a collective this she told
me that they're very strong
well-organized industry association and
she thought that if you know the right
mixture of carrots and sticks were in
place that they could could organize
amongst themselves and figure out much
more effective flexible and and
palatable ways for them to reduce their
their emissions as an industry relative
to what you know her ministry could have
come up with and so I thought that's
that's a very interesting possibility
and it's the sort of thing that comes
out of having a framework like Redd
where you have international rules being
set but really flexibility and freedom
given to individual countries or
sub-national units to figure out how
they will achieve the problem in their
own solution of the problem in their own
way so I was mentioning before that the
state almost disappear and that private
acto are substituting to eat sometimes
trying to do it in a responsive way to
give service to the world community but
the state didn't disappear completely
the state is poor but the state in Congo
is the only institution that has
representatives all over so basically
every small Atmos what if you need you
go you have an agronomist
you have a representative from the
Ministry of the Environment and those
people they know what they are talking
about they might not be the best to
appoint experts you know maybe but they
really know what they are talking about
because when I was mentioning you know
the quick eye of the number of night
someone is spending in a village those
people they spend a lot of time in the
village and talking with people and so I
think unfortunately they are totally
they are totally invisible even locally
even most project most and you basically
don't work with them and I think that's
little bit a shame and so they also
should be among us and tell us stories
about what they know about those
countries where we are walking and when
we try to do something caution against
like you know the caution against
ignoring too much the non-state actors I
think it's I think private engaging
private sector and thinking about the
demand and supply side of a lot of this
is hugely important not least because
the obviously the interests and the
influence of state actors but almost our
definition stops at national boundaries
but as as really importantly pointed out
in them so I didn't get your name
leakage does not stop at national
boundaries and and when we're talking
about global problems and global global
systems in terms of deforestation in
terms of carbon if we can solve the
problem in one country whatever shifts
it to another then as you point out
that's we haven't solved the problem at
all and the private sector also does not
stop and at national boundaries so if
you might halter companies or
commodities activities in one place but
it can easily shift to another one was
seeing that I guess with with palm oil
and global demand continues devised and
so maybe we can
nowaday the extent to which palm oil is
growing within a particular country but
if global demand continues to rise then
it will be produced somewhere and so I
think we need to take that more holistic
view I mean obviously state actors have
a part to play but I think I think it's
a complete solution by any means I
thought in response to your last
question the groups that I think would
be interesting to collaborate with our
you know discussions we had with Janis
yesterday in terms of rights and I think
in my work I work a lot with both state
agencies in Tanzania who are committed
to addressing rights based issues as
well as civil society actors like
grassroots organizations also in
Tanzania and
I think in the discussion of food
security rights to food is parallel and
integral to people's rights to use
forests right and so I think that how
will those rights be acknowledged and
how can we conceptualize that within
this food security debate but at the
same time this kind of red carbon market
debate and I think that's an interesting
Avenue to pursue in terms of how are
these people who are working in the food
security kind of sector looking at
rights and people's rights to food and
how does that relate to people's rights
in the forestry sector to use food use
forests for food so I think it's great
to see people collaborating with in
forestry and agriculture and nutrition
but also sort of expanding that to other
disciplines because Food and forestry
elite uh chah's everybody's lives such
as kind of increasing the collaborations
within disciplines I'd like to turn that
into the final part of the final
question for the panel which is very
much directed to the audience here who
are busy uncovering I think the the new
understanding deepening our
understanding of how the whole system
works and what we can do with it
I want to ask about the research
questions that are most critical to be
asking at this point and specifically
research questions which we might be
able to tackle within this group this
audience and this network of
practitioners
Jack was that I was waiting for the wave
coming from okay
very broad resist question very large
one everybody looks at the details
nobody tries to put the details all
together to get the big picture use the
microscope instead of the my sorry
excuse my accent microscope versus
microscope I mean use the big thing that
looks at the big picture
don't use the the big thing that look at
the the small details so as very broad
question pick up you know all the
knowledge that's already available there
and helps you to answer that question
and then fill the gaps build the
Purser's out of those piece and because
those are the questions policymakers
need in Madagascar policymakers need to
know how to stop deforestation and you
can accumulate tens and tens of PhD
known actually tries to answer that
question well the single research paper
I can think of that's most applicable to
this theme of the conference was was by
Foley at all professor at Minnesota and
it's called something like five
solutions for a for a cultivated planet
and it's it's in nature and it's this
big picture very macroscope thing and
it's you know I'm embarrassed that I
can't name all five but it's essentially
saying how do you produce agriculture
and you know keep a stable climate and
it's it has to do with food waste it has
to do with dietary shifts it has to do
with in agricultural intensification it
has to do with shifting where
cultivation occurs and you maybe someone
remembers the fifth and eighth I'm sure
we could also think and add sixth and
seventh but if you're out there as a PhD
student or doing research as a master's
student and thinking where do I do my
research I mean I think these are the
questions that will take you know a
thousand papers 20 years to to get an
answer to but every little piece of the
was gonna be very very helpful along the
way I think so a lot of research and
food security has been focused on
agricultural land to me that's I mean I
I asked the same question the second
yesterday our strain is a as a
agronomist to work in Green Revolution
in Punjab because Punjabis are going to
Appaloosa Navy so when they taught me
they never thought about producing food
in forest producing food in uncultivated
areas and the major focus was on
increasing yield from few crops so that
is I mean this that has been the reality
of reality of the attempts attempts to
produce more food I know I know
there has been critics and supporter of
the of the separates because it has led
to like in the last 50 years led to
three times increase in the yield of the
crops and we still think that with nine
million nine billion people coming by
2050 we need to an increase yield by
three more times for which we are going
into genetic engineering that's called
the second second generation giving the
revolution but we never have talked
about how to produce more food from
other landscape so I think more research
in this area will be very much useful
that's what I feel so maybe we should be
focusing more on the solutions rather
than the problems I mean looking at we
saw some beautiful complex agroforestry
systems that are producing global public
goods as well as local goods
how are those being sustained where the
systems where you see rich landscapes
being sustained by people what are the
neighbouring conditions for that can we
tease those out I mean I don't really
necessarily
and replicability but at least
understanding the conditions under which
those those rich landscapes can be
sustained and then trying to communicate
those underlying conditions to
policymakers instead of just focusing on
problems let's focus on actual you know
good examples and as some of these
concepts in the food and agriculture
world of sustainable intensification or
of climate smart agriculture or so you
say perhaps the the sustainable diet
idea gained currency but lack definition
there is an opportunity perhaps to take
some of these working models and insert
them at least their underlying
principles and conditions to create the
definition for these popular ideas that
right now lack much definition so
perhaps if you've got the good
agroforestry mosaic productive
multifunctional and that can somehow be
inserted as this is what we mean by
sustainable intensification it would be
a great service to the to the dialogue
who knows I do want to see if we've got
some time for some questions from the
audience to the panel at this point I'm
guessing since we started late we're
going to run a little bit over is that
okay so do we have roaming microphones
at this point I've got one here if
anyone wants a Roman mic and I think to
begin with right in front of me
I thank you much very much to everyone
who spoken throughout the whole past
three days one interesting thing for me
from this whole conference was I had
known from the forestry side that there
is this perspective of protected forests
without any agriculture but then that
there is such a variety going into use
of some sort sustainable use
agroforestry and then the nutrition side
surprised me because we think of
foresters environmentalists versus
agriculture and that it's not like that
necessarily that there might be big
industrial staple crop agriculture but
then there can also be smallholder
agriculture shifting agriculture and the
nutritionists themselves want
diversified systems and may even support
Agri forestry so through this I guess
agroforestry including shifting
cultivation and intercropping came up as
like oh yeah the answer and kind of like
what Diane just mentioned now my
question to you is is this something
that everyone in the in between the
strict forest reserves and the
industrial agriculture should be
rallying behind together is that
desirable is it possible or are there
problems with that please dad well
coming for I worked in world I Corps
forestry Center before going to US aid
and we we spent a lot of time promoting
different agroforestry systems in
different parts of Africa and I would I
would caution against a sort of
uncritical approach to promoting
agroforestry systems because there are a
lot of dimensions that relate to markets
and labor and just adding biomass to a
system there's a reason why people do
slash and burn or swidden because you
know it removes pests and diseases from
the system this is just maybe getting
into the weeds a little bit but you know
because I see when we talk about
sustainable intensification a lot of
energy around you know adding more
biomass to the system and just having
spent years and years sitting with
farmers and villages I would caution I
would really focus a lot of research on
how that's
happen with given labor requirements
given markets and given soil conditions
yeah agroforestry is really a funny
concept and it has a history you know in
the 80s a bunch of people where marveled
you know discovering agroforestry all
over the world discovering all those
traditional system that mix crops and
trees and there has been a few few
surveys you know all around the world to
identify those system making a topology
and and then I thought ok that's great
so let's really support that and in the
end the designer series of Technology
I like hoping in poor fellow control
strips and little by little I go
forestry became that it became those
technologies technological package
design based on a very committed
you know willingness to optimize
biophysical cycle between the crop and
the soil and there were super efficient
system bio physically but economically
or socially where they were not really
acceptable and eventually there was no
there is no big record of success of
adoption of those technologies and the
most extreme ones like a lake hoping was
even basically abandoned even by the
people who designed the system now it's
a kind of Oh out of fashion so the funny
thing is that when you go now still now
in the countryside you see and you
promote a group Westry who promote a
good forestry to get rid of agroforestry
because shifting cultivation is one of
those marvelous agroforestry system that
people you know admire in the beginning
and now it's all about getting rid of
that system and to replace it by the
agroforestry in the sense of the
technological package so that's a really
funny story I think it's also important
remember when you're but Agri first you
kind of deco that it's not all their
appropriate everywhere is when you're
bringing a new crop or a new tree to an
area you're not just bringing a material
substance that you have to bring the
knowledge of how to cultivate it you
have to if people are spending time on
that
there's something they're not spending
time on instead there's also a big
cultural context that has to come along
with just introducing new species to an
area a very quick comment I think the
challenge is not how to implement I
prefer its systems but how we can bring
the value back of agriculture to the
smallholders because most of the small
holders that we deal with especially in
the Amazon they don't want to be
agriculture anymore we have to bring
this value of planting of producing food
for them most of them are just cattle
ranchers or they just want to leave
their land to big land owners and then
move to the city so how we can bring it
back this value of really producing
their own food it's very quickly to
follow up because we were discussing
this earlier I mean staple food crop
production is a poverty trap in a lot of
places so and because of low purchasing
prices and just low returns to labor in
land so that's an issue that has to be
faced otherwise people are not going to
be able to afford any more complex
systems discussion of how we define our
problem definition whether we're talking
about food security or we were talking
about livelihoods outside of the frame
it seems and this isn't really a
critique of the panel or the conference
but more critique of time and what's
available in several presentations there
was a brief mention of my migration as
an approach as a strategy it seems that
as far as livelihoods go this is one
that is somewhat outside of the frame
and it's one that local people have used
as a response and it's one that occurs
in Madagascar and Yunnan in Nepal
certainly in the Congo and just to
represent not everything that happens
that decisions on the farmers very much
affected by what what's done off the
farm non-farm income and what
just any quick thoughts yeah so what
will happen in the first of Congo might
depend to how the local system of those
people living on the phones for as
Fantine will evolve but it will also
depend a lot on whole systems farming
systems in other areas where there is no
more forests from a while and whether
Savannah will evolve because people move
all the time they are looking for
opportunities so people in Savannah
moved to the forest when the sole
degrade but they don't like to move far
away because I like to be you know in a
place where they have a community where
there is an access to the market where
they can get some services so if you if
you do something about the to support
the agriculture in those seven Hazara
then they will stay and that will
alleviate the pressure on the forest so
and I agree that this is the other
connection that I'm not enough looked at
by bio policymakers also in Congo
there's a bunch of people who are really
aware of that but you you see them among
the mostly within the agricultural
sector because the environmental sector
they are really working on the forest
they don't see a lot the dynamic in the
in the seven areas where are the people
are really working on agricultural
intensification they are committed to do
something also about those seven areas
so that brings to the problem of
bringing on the table people are
addressing I will get your issues yeah
we really have to be talking about
robust rural economy so we have to be
talking about rural towns we have to be
talking about processing we have to be
talking about jobs and employment
because absent that you're again you're
going to get into poverty traps and
people wanting to leave and we were
talking about you know urban migration I
mean you're not going to stop that and
you're not going to get conservation and
better food security when the rural
areas are depopulated so it's a whole
system it's not just about you know food
production or forests it's really about
a whole production system that could be
more more investment
in rural towns and in secondary
industries that could attract people and
young people particularly thank you for
bringing up the global context of
urbanization to add to your migration
question there I don't know if it had
been fully addressed in some of the
discussions earlier so did you have a
comment or was that just a general
agreement are there two more questions
from the audience before we wrap things
up please I have a it is thought to
throw to the panel and to hear your
response to it and it started with
jagannath comment a couple of minutes
ago about the prospects of answering
some of the questions of our rising food
needs in areas outside of forested
landscapes and I know this is a
technological question but I want you to
imagine with me for a second what we
could do with the Sahara Desert for
example if we had the technology to
answer our food needs in that space it
would probably solve the problem for a
couple of people and so the
conservationists would be happy because
his forest is not being degraded and the
multinational companies that need palm
oil would have the land that they need I
would like to hear your thoughts on that
question because my colleague and I were
speaking a few minutes ago and the truth
is the people who are growing food are
doing it for two reasons they're either
growing food at the subsistence level
for their families or they're growing it
for business so how do we bridge that
gap and are there solutions outside of
the food forest dialogue too that can
you know answer the question for both
ends of the puzzle I think the main
point is not about only forest that is
being converted to produce food but we
have to think about converting native
vegetation because what is going on in i
was mentioned brazil again sorry but
forests like the amazon is pretty well
conserved right now but what we are we
have we are seen is that all the food
production is going to the savanna to
Brazil and a handle so what we want is
not only to conserve the forest but
conserve native vegetation in general so
we have to use already opening plant and
I think it's not an issue of technology
because we have space is how to use
those the space that is already open or
the areas they're already cleared in a
more efficient way and we have
technology for this I think is much more
about public policies to incentivate
those producers to go to those areas may
be the context I imagine was was in the
pump so it could be different things but
what I was saying is like I mean clearly
there are different land uses within a
landscape agricultural land is there
there were berries uncultivated land
boosts land forests and within forests
different types of forests in terms of
management style and in terms of
composition of the forest structure of
the forest so my main concern is I mean
we need to go for sustainable
intensification of the farmland that's
there but country like Nepal not only
faces food insecurity from like excess
point of view but also the availability
is low so we need to increase
availability of all kinds of food
wherever is possible that's what I'm
saying so yesterday I think it was there
was a comparison between a system way
traditionally managed forests wiki was
cultivated and then a monoculture tree
was there so the thing is what I'm
saying is
most of the research most of the visas
funding from development agencies
international agencies goes for
promoting monoculture in the farm but if
we also had kind of because we do
research for improvement so if we had
more research on
like agroforestry system we can produce
more food better food it would certainly
increase our fully stock there are other
question of excess is there but we also
have to increase the for stock that's
what I was saying so we we had a very we
our traditional farming system is very
complex producing diversified system
somehow the present this green
revolution system is not able to capture
that whole dynamics of the traditional
food production system so the only thing
now saying is we need more visas to to
produce more food from such system
without destroying the system so we need
to do more business and that's what I
was mentioning yeah I think you bring up
an excellent point and I'd like to
reiterate Brazil as a success story
Karen showed us that really striking
figure that that everybody should know
that's that scene Brazil's deforestation
go down by more than 80 percent in the
last decade and the climate contribution
of that has been as great or even
greater than all of Europe under the
Kyoto Protocol I mean a massive global
significant climate impact of stopping
deforestation and and what what wasn't
there but but I find just as interesting
is that soy production and cattle
production didn't drop by eighty percent
over that time period it didn't even
drop by one percent it went up it was it
was going up up up over that same time
period and the main reason for that was
more and more efficient production in
the non forest areas and so I think you
bring up a great point of sort of
decoupling the places where the the
deforestation you know the forest
frontier activities are occurring in
your agricultural intensification
activities are occurring because as
Francis pointed out in her keynote it's
it's probably there's reasons to be very
wary of increasing the intensification
in those same villages at the frontier
because you're bringing in technologies
that make land more profitable to clear
those very lands but it may be the case
you've got a breadbasket somewhere in
Brazil that's far far away from the the
current frontier areas in Brazil and
then you start drawing the migration
that one of the previous question is
brought up on the economic growth just
away from the forests well I think we
could be doing a lot more and lot more
is being done in urban and peri-urban
spaces with the right incentives I don't
know about you guys but I grow a lot of
some of my own food in my backyard in
Washington DC and the kalos City
movement is big in DC a lot of people
are using community supported
agriculture that's close into the city
and and that you know has the potential
for increasing the space for food
production you know closer into urban
populations there's a very big
difference between doing agriculture in
forests and doing it in Savannah or in
area which has maybe not the same
potential in my immediately visible when
you do a quickie tour in the forest you
just need an axe and a match and seeds
you use the natural capital you convert
it into fertilizer and you have a bloom
of cassava it's beautiful and you feed
your family if you don't have a disease
in the field now if you do a quick
review on on the Savannah well the soil
is not the same it's hard it has been
degraded by files of other years usually
it's an ant report on toppling system
not always but it's often an
entrepreneur degraded ecosystem so you
need to invest something you need to
constitute a capital of exploitation and
and this causes many policymakers to
consider they should give the savanna to
the agribusiness because they're a great
business has the money so the
counterpart I mean the the corollary of
shifting the frontier from the forest to
the Savannah is that you have to devise
to design a policy that's going to
support the small holders to acquire
this capital X of exploitation
which can be you know a pair of oxen and
a pro which can be a card to evacuate
the product which can be maybe why not
it's not taboo something to fertilizer
or something to get rid of the weeds
because you have more weeds and so to
accompany this transition by providing
or providing the right support otherwise
you give the 7r to the agribusiness and
what's left to the smallholder is the
forest I just like to throw in a little
bit of a cautionary case study and then
take the final question your question
about applying technology and capital
especially in areas that are non
forested or what would be considered
marginal it just brought to mind the
largest dairies that exist in the world
the largest dairy systems that exist in
the world right now which are in the
deserts in Saudi Arabia and I don't know
if you've taken a look through some of
these systems but they're kind of the
the pinnacle of industrial agriculture
if you will absolutely vast very very
low labour inputs astronomical capital
and fossil fuel inputs because of course
it's essentially a vast hydroponic
system growing in the complete absence
of soil pumping up water from far down
below drawing it out at tremendous rates
and then using every latest a
technological tool in the agronomic
toolbox to create these huge huge dairy
systems growing alfalfa and feed grains
and putting them into these massive
dairies out in the desert and if you
look at of course the long-term
prospects for replicating a system like
that there are really no other countries
in the world where you would find the
right combination of excessive fossil
fuel availability and capital
availability and then the downstream
consequences of actually burning that up
if you had it you all know where that
goes the energetics of it are not
particularly good so I guess just
looking at what the implications are as
you pursue the technology intensive
capital intensive
cultivation of the more marginal areas
in the world and how that affects it we
do have some case studies out there that
can let you know what that trajectory
ends up with so I just offer that a
final question and that goes to Jeff
hi thanks everyone for your fascinating
perspectives on these issues I was a
grower in the Hudson Valley for a few
years four five five seasons before I
came here now I'm studying ecology
carbon cycling and nitrogen cycling and
agroforestry applications for temperate
climates there's been a consortin census
here or at least a common thread of
looking at the political ecology and
policy solutions for these types of
questions of food and forests and I'm
curious as someone who's studying
ecology now if there are basic science
and applied science questions that you
feel over the next 10 years could
contribute to the work that you're doing
or if the questions really are a hybrid
nature of applying scientific solutions
that already exist of generating the
political will power or the policy
solutions to create you know some
answers to these questions or if as a
young ecologist there's questions that
you'd like me to focus on ok so the
basic research question that I think is
really important which I'm starting to
focus on is sort of looking at the
impacts of climate change on food
quality which i think is a really
fascinating research question and if
they're agricultural forestry methods to
sort of mitigate the impacts of climate
change on food quality okay yeah I think
it's one very important determinant of
what gets talked about and what policy
gets made for and in climate and Forests
is what can be measured scientifically
and so you hear a lot about reducing
even though red plus is reducing
emissions from deforestation degradation
enhancing stocks sustainable management
in the end 80 90 percent of the
conversation is about reducing emissions
from deforestation and there's some
political reasons for that but I think
the biggest reason is raw natural
science reason which is that we have
gotten quite good at measuring the
carbon fluxes from land-use change
taking a forest and putting it into
agriculture that's pretty well known you
can track the areas by satellite and
contract the carbon changes what's
lagging far behind is knowledge and
ability to monitor the carbon cycle
within land uses within a forest under
different types of management within
these you know agro pastoral systems and
so if and when the the raw science is
able to catch up the policy will move
forward - and and that will be that will
have a great effect in that it will
expand the pool of beneficiaries from
those countries the the more especially
the more wealthy of the developed
countries where you see large land use
change - some of the poorer especially
African countries where what's going on
is degradation changes of land use
management and in drawing down of carbon
within the forests so my if I had a
choice I'd say work on that dam
yeah I discussed with my colleagues here
working on complex agroforestry systems
where are the critters to channel my
conservation colleagues back in
Washington you know where do they fit in
these systems how do we fit them in how
do we measure them we still don't have a
lot we don't really know enough about
faunal biodiversity in red we haven't
focused enough attention on it and we're
not going to get the full support of
conservation until we can show that
faunal biodiversity has a place in these
both our beloved complex agroforestry
systems charismatic figure and not as
bushmeat necessarily although I'm not
ruling that out either
the moles will be back unless we are the
right combinations of carrots and sticks
in metaphors Jacques I think if you
could download the Library of Congress
into your brain you will not really need
to do any more research I'm really
wondering seriously what do we still
have to study I mean we always can find
something but every time we think we
have a great idea if we do a broad
literature review we can find out that
someone already address that and maybe
even twenty years ago but something you
can something you would still need is I
mean once you have download your the
Library of Congress if you go to work
with the community or in an
administration with the Ministry of with
any institution that doesn't mean you're
going to be able to solve the problem
that doesn't mean you have the solution
so what you can still do is solve the
problem with them using all the Library
of Congress that's in your brain or at
least everything that you can reasonably
acquire as knowledge so that means that
maybe the kind of research we we have to
do now should be more involved and there
are various schools of that we call that
action research also you have to be very
careful about the world because it's
like cream cake you know you can put
everything in their world it doesn't
mean that it's actually that but yeah I
think the way to make one more step is
to be really engaged in stakeholder and
because that's the way we can learn the
stuff that are still missing maybe I
will add to that there there are some
physical science questions that we're
still in our very very early stages of
understanding you talked about the
certainty engaged with carbon modeling
at a big scale the greenhouse gases that
are implicated in agriculture the
nitrous oxide and methane some of those
are there's there's still a lot to be
uncovered about how those fluxes work
how those cycles work did an interesting
back-of-the-envelope on canada's
reporting of their nitrous oxide
emissions and the uncertainty that was
implicated in that meant that if there
was a not unusually wet year in southern
ontario under
fertilization regimes that there was an
uncertainty in that greenhouse gas
emission that exceeded the entire civil
aviation sector of Canada just based on
what may or may not have been
volatilized through fertilization under
not abnormal conditions these are still
areas where the models are far from
clear when it comes to some of these
greenhouse gases but my interest is
really in as a research question is how
can we capture value and communicate in
value from multiple functions how can we
take all of the benefits that are
reported for these systems that offer
the resilience that they're touted for
and actually identify what those are and
communicate them using hopefully the
Equality turn which is the interest in
the urbanizing population growing in
wealth who wants more quality either
through health or through impact on a
larger environment how do we bridge that
gap between saying here's the multiple
values we've expressed them and we can
market them and tie them to that growing
in affluence urban consumer which is
popping up like moles everywhere
with that though I want to thank very
much the panel all of the attendees here
and turn it back over to Julia to give
the final housekeeping and thank-yous
and farewells I just want to thank the
panelists again can we give them some
applause for coming here
[Music]
[Applause]
and also to our moderators thanks mark
for doing such a great job and our
poster presenters thank you so much and
again to the highest EF team here I
can't think of people I would rather
work with and have organized this
conference with you guys are amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
okay go away and I just want to remind
you guys everyone that all of these
panels and discussions are available on
the Yale YouTube right now so you can
share them with collaborators and
students and colleagues and I hope that
we can keep discussing how to coordinate
agriculture and forestry and nutrition
and the panelists who need rides
downtown or to the train station please
meet at their reception table and also
ask
you